Moin, oder was da was ist eigentlich das Gegenteil
von moin guten abend für die tagesschau wahrscheinlich sagen würde
nee kein plan ich bin auch mal wieder da
ganz nach heute rum gebastelt ans heuch
ich kann jetzt mal ein hoftor mit einem zig pi button auf und zu machen
nein nicht ganz nur die eine seite aber immerhin schon mal
andere seite muss ich noch den nachbar fragen ob er an sein haus was dran bohren kann
aber ich habe jetzt ein zig pi button und den kann ich drücken den klebe ich ins
auto und dann kann ich da drauf drücken und dann gehts hoftor auf
besser als die originale fern ja mit neuer job ich glaube der titel ist
bisschen gebait ich will heute was erstellen für eventuell also für den
eventuellen neuen job also ich glaube vielleicht muss ich den
titel vielleicht muss ich den ich glaube ich muss den titel anders machen
glaube ich muss den titel anders machen wir erstellen heute was für die
bewerbung für den neuen job was heißt bewerbung
bewerbung schreiben wir heute nicht
ich ändere den ich ändere komm ich lasse jetzt neue job dann fragen wir 30
mit jahren leute nach ist doch aus aulern verkehrt
ne ne anschreiben machen wir nicht ne ne anschreiben machen wir nicht
anschreiben brauche ich in dem fall nicht weil ich jemanden kenne und das
ohne anschreiben ne aber was ich was ich machen muss ist
was zum
ich weiß nicht was mir dieser dieser satz sagen soll ein erwartetes
deliverable vom unternehmen deliverable ist das marketing speech auch was
influencer ads und sowas angeht aber was was möchtest du mir sagen huli kon
salami ja bis theoretisch ich wollte nicht klick beten habe mir jetzt
aufgefallen ist es ein bisschen clickbait wir erstellen heute was was ich
brauche dass ich den neuen job kriege das ok ich muss den titel echt anders
machen die leute glauben alle ich habe neuen job ich habe vielleicht ich habe
vielleicht bald einen neuen job aber noch habe ich den nicht so ich ich
ändere mal den titel fange ich bei der bahn an also ich muss ein lebenslauf
erstellen das machen wir aber nicht im stream aus obvius reasons ja und
was nein erwartet keiner projekt aber danke schon trotzdem der eichler für
38 monate massive also ok ok ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was aktuell sache ist
also nachdem ich das letzte video hochgeladen habe nachdem ich dieses
video hier hochgeladen hat hat sich direkt im anschluss per mail jemand
gemeldet den ich noch von früher kennen und hat gemeint max willst nicht bei uns
arbeiten wir haben nice job für dich dann hätte ich zum ersten mal ich meine
es nicht dass ich da wirklich wert drauf lege er aber da hätte ich zum ersten mal
senior ganz offiziell im titel drin stehen was ja auch für mich passt weil
boomer also ab gewissen alda kann man das ja ruhig ruhig haben so zumindest ich
brauche kein anschreiben oder sonst was einzige was ich machen muss ist ja ich
muss lebenslauf erstellen und das ist das was wir heute mal ich muss eine eine
skill übersicht oder skill liste erstellen was ich alles schon gemacht
habe beziehungsweise nicht weiß alles was was was ich denn denke zu können und ja
genau endlich sehe ich meine ich bin schon wenn du so willst in der
position lange aber ich hatte nie senior im titel so das heißt wir müssen uns
deswegen was aus den fingern saugen ich weiß auch gar nicht genau wie man das
macht und wie man das am besten kopiert und ja keine ahnung ich mein ich habe
zuletzt bewerbung vor vor frag mich nicht das ist lange lange lange her geschrieben
zumindest muss ich reinschreiben so was wie 15 jahre linux erfahrung
kobold mit den projekten ja gut mit dem surfer in der wohnung du meinst das
ding was durchs fenster reingehoben wurde ja ja das war was was keck wie
also der bewerbungsprozess sieht folgendermaßen aus mich hat ein ex
kollege angerufen nach dem video hat gefragt mags willst du nicht den job bei
uns so habe ich gesagt ja klingt gut der hat sich übelst motiviert angehört aber
ich hab was brauchst du denn von mir hat er gesagt der soliste mit was du kannst
und lebenslauf und dann können wir ab 1 november dann weitermachen so soll mir
recht sein mein singert gute vorlagen ich habe vorhin bei google geguckt ich
habe nix gefunden wenn du mir sagst wie das zeug heißt nach was ich suchen muss
oder du darfst sogar links schicken im chat dann wäre ich euch sehr verbunden
chat allerdings links zu skill ist und lebensläufen und ich weil lebenslauf
vorlage habe ich aber eine wort vorlage monka ist ich weiß nicht ob ich ernsthaft
wort macht seine kündigungsfrist zu kurz nein nein nein ich sage nicht dass ich
am 1 november anfangen sondern dass wir dann am 1 november uns das genauer
angucken ob das überhaupt passt ja mit mit geld und und allem ob man damit
beidseitig einverstanden ist anschreiben ich brauche kein anschreiben ich brauche
eine liste mit skills was ich alles kann und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie ich
die machen soll soll ich da einfach nur auflisten soll ich einstellt soll ich
dabei schreiben wie viele jahre erfahrung soll ich dabei schreiben so wie gut nach
was kopiere ich das ich habe ich habe keine ahnung ok kann man kann man das
anzeigen mal nicht dass es irgendeine porn seite ist oder sowas man weiß ja
nie
ich brauche weder lebenslauf noch anschreiben doch lebenslauf brauche ich
an wie was für fach wird er für meine das will ich einfach mal just for fun
wesen was da drin steht niemand bewirbt sich als fachinformatiker niemand
sorry leute aber niemand bewirkt bewirbt sich als fachinformatiker auf die
ausbildung vielleicht
braucht kein lebenslauf ich brauche irgendeine skillliste wo ich super krasses
cloud native pfeiffer zeug drauf schreiben kann das jetzt kommt
anschreiben.com das ist jetzt die porn seite oder
wie gesagt ich brauche das für nicht für leben ich sehe es gerade ich brauche
das nicht für lebenslauf sondern skills bringt mir so nichts ich mache jetzt
erst mal eine liste und dann gucke ich mal was man da reinschreiben was ist
denn mehr was man so kann zum beispiel 15 jahre linux erfahrung mit
redhead cento es ubuntu debian so zeug ja
wie gesagt ich brauche kein ich brauche kein lebenslauf leute reicht wörth doch
ich mag wörth aber nicht reichen tut das bestimmt aber dann muss man wörth
abnutzen ich habe keine ahnung leute mir geht es eher um den inhalt
aber ja warum sagen alle ich soll bei der mit alles genau warum soll alle sagen
alle ich soll bei der bahn arbeiten als würde ich freiwillig bei der bahn
empfangen
ja also ich werde auf jeden fall also die das heute schreiben auf jeden fall in
markt dauer
wir hatten doch irgendwo letzten so eine programmier skilliste skills wenn wir
das machen skills so progas hieß das oder so
ok das muss ich mal entmiemt wirklich sinnvoll aufschreiben klein ok kann man
nicht sagen schließen alles außer dass
close others
oder gehen wir nicht auf den keks er muss jetzt bei allem und einer lasst
sich halt offen die suche jeden monat ja das ist richtig
eventuell schicke ich das als pdf lebenslauf integriert das skill ist das
6 hat sein zeig mal
jetzt wird es jetzt geht es aber ab alter das sieht aber ganz schön old
school aus computer skills und languages computer java schaab
der rast glasingly fast das sponsor video leute zu geil das sponsor video
ist seit wann ist mittwoch gewesen hier das hat drei tagen ist das fertig das
sponsor video und ich habe es bis heute nicht geschafft mit den link zu schicken
jetzt müssen sie warten bis nächste woche weil morgen lade ich dann
wahrscheinlich was zur mw2 hoch mal gucken edv kenntnis ja ganz wichtig kann
man kann man kann man nicht von ausgehen wenn man sich darauf bewirbt dass man
edv kenntnisse hat jammel ja wenn ich will dass sie so gleich abgefuckt sind
wenn sie es öffnen müssen dann mache ich es als jammel ja wenn es um die
bahn geht schon naja gucken wir mal
so machen wir es ja das klingt gut ich würde sagen noch mit after effects wie
gesagt das ist der inhalt ist jetzt erst mal das problem jetzt nicht so sehr wie
das wie das wie das ausschaut ja leute ich habe heute was gesehen hat jetzt hat
nichts wirklich gar nichts mit bewerbung zu tun ich habe ein video gesehen da
ging es darum dass also erst mal habe ich gedacht auch
nehme ich schon wieder dieses thema ja dass irgendwie auch wie schreibe wie
sagen sie das auf englisch irgendwie overwatch 2 wäre kein safe environment
und sowas ja also wo die leute dann super toxik sind und harassed werden und
sowas diese themen eigentlich bin ich leid ja jeder ist überall am rum rum
heulen aber leute heute habe ich ein video gesehen das war wirklich ich ich
wusste nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen soll ja und zwar irgendjemand hat für
overwatch 2 einen custom spiel modus gemacht und jetzt passt mal auf
vielleicht vielleicht soll ich ich kann ich muss mal kurz gucken vielleicht ich
zeige euch das video ich muss aber vorspulen ich muss aber vorspulen
wie ist das e-sport report ist port moment
ja genau genau genau genau genau das ist das weg
moment das sekunde sekunde moment moment wo ich jetzt mal kurz checken
nee ist nicht weg
ich muss vorspulen leute leute ihr werdet ihr werdet wirklich ihr werdet
sich glauben die leute sind so abgefuckt verrückt und gestört mittlerweile
pass mal auf ich spule mal vor ansonsten ist das video nicht
sonderlich interessant ok
ok also
irgendeiner hat sich auf twitter darüber beschwert dass es sexual
harassment spielmodi gibt in in overwatch 2 und da habe ich mir gedacht
hä wie was was meint die und die zeigen das jetzt gleich leute es ist so
gestört es ist so gestört
ich hoffe das ist nicht zu laut ihr werdet ihr werdet euch auf der einen
seite weg pissen auf der anderen seite versteht ihr die welt nicht mehr es ist
es ist ein ganz komisches gefühl mit dem ein called sexual harassment and one
game that's simulated female characters being ok thankfully my son realized it
was bad close the game and told me don't play hashtag overwatch land is also the
partner a famous twitch streamer lemmy ane das ist das ist nicht so das nicht
so wild wo ist das denn hier das nicht so spannend ist es denn hier genau also
das ist der custom das ist der custom spielmodus den jemand in overwatch
nachgebaut hat sexual harassment simulator mit mccree mit mccree das
passt auch noch richtig gut zu der ganzen blizzard geschichte ja mit mccree
und jetzt zeigen sie ein bisschen gameplay wartet mal wo ist das gameplay
bensch wo ist das gameplay hier hier ok
play the sexual harassment simulator custom mode where there then is text
saying months of pregnancy in the top right corner eventually seems as if the
player who's playing a character that is a woman is stunned and then teabagged
losing health until their death they respawned with the mission changing the
top right corner to go home and then wait until your baby is this is so
gestört cgamer.com when you enter it it forces one player to play as cassidy
against a team of strictly female overwatch heroes the top left of the
screen instructs you to flash to knock down your victims which refers to
cassidy's old overwatch one flashbang ability and then that's a tea bag to
which is written with spaces seemingly to get around a word filter as you
crouch text appears on the top of the screen that says raping enemy heroes are
then marked as das ist schon wirklich hart gestört ja dass die leute auf so eine
idee kommen so was zu bauen aber jetzt jetzt kommt gleich dass ich ich wusste
mich so weg wegschmeißen pregnant eventually a torbjorn bot ist das kind
so gestört screen that says raping enemy heroes are then marked as pregnant
eventually a torbjorn bot is spawned to simulate a child in its simplest form is
a game mode that simulates sexual harassment simulator gepaart in overwatch
und als porn torbjorn bot ist ich weiß ich ich finde das auf der einen seite
mega beschissen auf der anderen seite lustig das ist ganz komisches gefühl
ich weiß nicht es ist schon wieder möglich verrückt auf was für leute auf
was für ideen die leute kommen man
war wirklich eines der gestörtesten dinge die ich in letzter zeit gesehen
ab was weiß ich keine ahnung ich habe es nicht ausprobiert oh mann nix feelings
genau
meine güte neuer job nein ich habe noch noch habe ich den neuen job nicht wir
müssen etwas schreiben für den neuen job das eine skill ist erstellen
ich habe extra den titel geändert weil ich so fühle weil viele gebaited waren
das war gar nicht die absicht was geht hier ab was anderes als im titel steht
gerade ne noch nicht noch nicht
was würdest du als streamer es ok finden wenn du für einen wenn du für ein
steam game deinen twitch stream key in will da was auf steam releasing wofür
das nötig wäre du brauchst du wirklich den stream key kannst du nicht über die
twitch api was machen kommt drauf an kommt drauf an was es ist ob ich das
machen will und ob das irgendwie einen vertrauenswürdigen eindruck macht also
so pauschal in einem random game würde ich nicht meinen mein streaming key
eingeben
was wir jetzt et suchen
was willst du dann machen oder willst nicht verraten weil neue
neue, krasse Geschäftsidee.
A melon man?
Ich hoffe ich hab das richtig endlit speaked.
Ey will er, will er, will er wahrscheinlich nicht beraten.
Nun gut, man muss uns mal Gedanken machen, also chat ich brauch heute eure Hilfe, eurer 5-head Schwarmintelligenz, was man da alles reinschreiben könnte und vor allem in welche Kategorien man das eintellen könnte und sonst was.
Ich fang erstmal mit einfachen Sachen an, die mir sofort einfallen.
Ich mein man muss das jetzt auch nicht 50 Seiten lang machen ja.
Es reicht ja wenn es ein bisschen Relevanz für den Job hat.
Danny Dankeschön für den Zapp, nee hat gar nicht gesagt Dankeschön für den Gifted Zapp an den Murkser.
Falls du Zertifikat hast, ja ich hab in Cisco CCNA gemacht vor über 10 Jahren, ich glaube das kann er mir sparen.
Ich weiß es noch nicht, wahrscheinlich mach ich es wirklich in Markdown, da muss ich mir kein Word geben.
Achja na gut.
Ich brauch kein Tool dafür.
Ja ob ich, ob ich was von Twitch und Technics Film und so überhaupt da reinschreibe, ich glaube nicht, ich will ja gar nicht, dass man das großartig weiß.
Ich kann in Twitch Emotes reden, nicer Skill ja.
Dankeschön Unrun Dead für 6 Monate Massive Subscriptions.
Sorry falls ich irgendjemand übersehen habe, ich glaube nicht.
Speedmaster Rock, doch hier Leute, ich muss doch mal kurz gucken, ich hab bestimmt wieder noch mehr übersehen.
Sekunde Leute, das geht ja nicht.
Wen hatten wir heute hier schon?
Unrun Dead, Spenny, Speedrun Master Rock, Murkser, der Eichler.
Dankeschön Leute für den Sub, für die Subs.
So, also bewirb dich bei Nord, was soll ich bei Nord vp an?
Sir Gentlefrog, Massive Subscription, Sixer Time.
So Leute, geh mal fort hier Visual Studio.
Das ist euch nicht so langweilig, jetzt lasse ich mal den Chat im Hintergrund laufen.
Wobei der Chat läuft eh unten rechts, was auch immer, da passiert ein bisschen was im Hintergrund.
Wir wissen ja Aufmerksamkeit Spange, nicht Aufmerksamkeit Spange, Aufmerksamkeit Spanne.
Hab auch noch ein anderes Video geguckt auf YouTube, weil ich auch wieder, irgendwie fällt mir jetzt gerade der ganze Schwachsinn ein.
Das ist typische Vermeidungstaktik, kennt ihr das Leute?
Wenn ihr was machen wollt, wo ihr irgendwie gar keinen richtigen Bock drauf habt, dann macht ihr alles, aber nicht damit anfangen.
Jetzt fällt mir ein, weil ich alles auf YouTube schon geguckt hab heute, so ein Blödsinn.
Ich hab auf YouTube heute ein Video geguckt.
Beziehungsweise ich hab erst auf Twitter was gelesen, so ein Ausschnitt aus irgendeiner Dating Show oder sowas.
Ist irgendwie schon eine Woche her, da war ein Typ, das war irgendwie so Blind Date.
Und die sollten dann halt miteinander reden und dann halt irgendwie, sobald sie keinen Bock mehr aufeinander hatten, konnten sie so einen Buzzer drücken.
Und da war ein Asiater dabei, der hat immer, sobald er festgestellt hat, dass er dicken Mädels gegenüber sitzt, hat er immer direkt den Buzzer gedrückt.
So nach dem Buzzer, nein, nein, dicken Mädels, keinen Bock, Buzzer, Next, Buzzer, Next.
Obwohl er die Augen verbunden hat, da hat er es immer irgendwie rausgekriegt.
So und auf Twitter, Leute, die sind alle wieder komplett ausgerastet.
Genau, genau, genau, der hat die gehackt und dann rausbekommen, dass die etwas pepo-fat sind.
Aber das hat natürlich nicht lange auf sich warten lassen, dass das wieder ein ganz böser Frauenhasser ist laut Twitter.
Und ganz, ganz furchtbar schlimm, wie sie sich alle aufregen, nein, ich will mich gar nicht so lange darüber auslassen.
Findest du easy, Michael, wenn du das sagst.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, wisst ihr was?
Eigentlich ist das doch komplett dem seine Sache, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum sich da wieder so viele aufspielen auf Twitter oder generell wieder so viele aufspielen.
Wenn er nicht will, will er nicht, ist doch sein Ding.
Ich verstehe die Aufregung nicht.
Ja, natürlich ist das dumm.
Ich gebe dir recht, dass das das Konzept dieser Sendung etwas ad absurdum führt.
Aber nicht desto trotz, also für die Sendung ist es dumm, ja.
Aber nicht desto trotz ist es ja an sich nichts Schlimmes.
Der kann doch gut finden, was er will.
Aber wie er wieder gehatet wird, man.
Wisst ihr, das sind so die super krass toleranten Leute, die ihn quasi dafür flamen, dass er nicht tolerant genug ist,
aber ihn fertig machen wollen bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Was ja auch wieder super tolerant ist.
Ich finde es wieder lustig, wie sich Twitter aufgeregt hat, man.
Ich dachte mir so Ja, okay, ganz ehrlich.
Also die eine von den beiden fand ich gar nicht übel.
Aber da hat sie ja nicht gesehen.
Und wenn er nicht will, man ist doch sein Bier.
Auf Twitter, auf Twitter sind teilweise das stimmt gar nicht.
Es sind halt die, die rumschreien, sind auf Twitter wirklich, wirklich ätzend.
Umgedreht hätte doch auch keiner was gesagt.
Ja, wenn es irgendwie, wenn irgendwie einer sagt, ja, ich will keine dicken Typen.
Ah ja, ist halt so.
Oder umgedreht, wenn irgendwie einer sagt, ja, müssen alle irgendwie zwanzig, dreißig Kilo zu viel haben.
Who cares?
Jeder, was er, was er, was er, was er, was, was ihn scharf macht, ja, was, was ihm, ihr gefällt.
Ist dir da überhaupt keine Probleme drin?
Oh je, das wird noch zunehmen in nächster Zeit.
Da geht noch mehr ab.
Vielleicht kommt ja sogar Trump wieder zurück auf Twitter.
Oh Leute, das ist Weltuntergang.
Dann rasten sie alle aus.
Ja, wenn es danach geht, darfst du ja zunächst irgendwas sagen.
Am besten, am besten finde ich immer noch die Kommentare so nach dem Motto.
Wie?
Warum kritisierst du das?
Mach's doch erst mal selbst besser.
Wo ich mir immer denke, Alter, man kann auch was kacke finden, ohne es selbst besser zu können.
Wenn mein Touchscreen auf dem Handy Pixelfehler hat, kann ich sagen, kacke Display.
Und dann kann ich nicht erst ein eigenes Touchdisplay bauen, bis ich sagen darf, kacke Display.
Okay, okay, hier geht's, hier geht's los.
Gutes Grundgruß für Skills in dem Umfeld, Programmierspanne.
Ja, tatsächlich an diese Sachen in der Richtung habe ich auch schon gedacht.
Aber ich finde das gut.
Ich mache das mal hier rein.
IoT könnte man noch dabei machen, habe ich auch ein paar Sachen schon gemacht.
Ich meine nicht, dass es jetzt dafür groß brauchen würde.
Mach's doch selber, ja.
Hast du heute Morgen im Rad?
Ja, es gibt immer noch so viele Leute, die damit anfangen.
Ich gebe zu, manchmal gibt es ganz neue Perspektiven, wenn man selbst mal was versucht hat
und dann feststellt, ach, so einfach ist das ja gar nicht.
Nichtsdestotrotz traf trotzdem jeder Sachen gerade, die er bezahlt hat und gekauft hat
und die nicht so funktionieren, wie er das gerne hätte, kritisieren.
Warum nicht?
Message Queues, oh jetzt, High IQ Gramm.
Message Queue, da schreibe ich MQTT rein.
PubSub, PubSub ist auch so High IQ Wort, da stehen auch alle drauf.
PubSub.
Azure Functions.
Blockchain, Blockchain kann ich nicht reinschreiben, davon habe ich keine Ahnung.
IOT Object, siehst du, deswegen habe ich euch chat.
Also ich fange jetzt erstmal mit sinnvollen Sachen an.
Sobald euch was, Protobuf, Protobuf, GRPC, sobald euch was einfällt, sagt Bescheid.
Also ich fange jetzt erstmal an mit Sachen, die easy sind, die mir schnell einfallen.
Also lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Das offensichtlichste ist natürlich Linux, aber 15 Jahre Linux Erfahrung.
Da schreibe ich aber 15 Jahre rein, aber 15 Jahre sind schon vim, vim, excellent, vim.
Cloud, Cloud, Cloud wollte ich auch reinschreiben.
Ne Emacs schreibe ich halt rein, Emacs habe ich eine Weile mal verwendet, aber nicht,
dass ich das irgendwie geil finden würde oder großartig, da jetzt der krasse Email
der Elisp Hacker wäre. Ok, also Linux Erfahrung, Red Hat CentOS,
beziehungsweise CentOS ist ja dead, nennen wir es Red Hat, Red Hat, heißt es Derivate?
Schreibt man das so?
Klon, Klon, Klons, können wir schreiben.
Ach keine Ahnung, Red Hat CentOS reicht doch.
Ubuntu, Debian, die wichtigsten abzudecken.
Ok, Alpine, ja, ne.
Archby, was soll ich das?
Jetzt schreibe ich halt rein.
Je nachdem, je nachdem wer da sitzt, findet das entweder mega lustig oder er checkt es nicht.
Also insofern kann man eigentlich verlieren, wenn es drin steht.
Ja, der große Kubernetes Checker bin ich halt. Ok Leute, lass mal ein bisschen themenbezogen das Ganze machen.
Ok, also fangen wir mal, nennen wir das mal Linux, so als Überschrift, ja.
Ok, ok, Pfeiffer teilen, Samba kann jeder, irgendwie ein bisschen.
Ich würde ja ZFS reinschreiben, aber ich meine, ich habe eine Weile ZFS betrieben,
aber es ist nicht so, als hätte ich da großartig Plan.
Können wir mal reinschreiben, warum nicht?
Der Fiat Champ, der muss rein.
So, Webserver schreiben wir mal rein, so die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Engine X, gibt es irgendjemand, der Engine X immer auf den ersten Anlauf richtig schreibt?
Engine X, Kaddy, oh wie schreibt man Traffic?
Traffic, irgendwie so.
Wir könnten das auch Reverse Proxy nennen.
HA Proxy, tatsächlich ein bisschen zumindest.
Apache, Apache habe ich tatsächlich am wenigsten Ahnung von.
Let's Encrypt, Squid, ja weiß nicht, ob man das da überhaupt alles reinschreiben muss,
eigentlich unsinnig, aber wenn euch noch irgendwas zertifikat,
ich habe nur einen CCNA vor üblichen Zeiten gemacht.
Und das habe ich keine Ahnung.
Staubsauger, mein Staubsauger hat Ubuntu.
Nennen wir das mal, DevOps Zeug.
Okay, Git, nicht GitLab, Alter, GitHub, GitHub Actions.
Ich schreibe jetzt mal, was mir so einfällt.
Ist es gängig, dass man, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe sowas noch nie gemacht.
Ich schreibe jetzt erst mal alles auf, was mir so einfällt und dann mal gucken,
was man da draus macht.
Was du mit dem Staubsauger verpasst hast?
Ich habe einen Staubsauger, auf dem Ubuntu läuft.
12.04, dann 14.04 und ich glaube, mittlerweile 16.04.
Und dann wird dann, ich glaube, auf 20.04 wurde dann nie geupdatet.
Hast du schon von dem neuen Job erzählt?
Naja, habe ich, habe ich erzählt, aber wie gesagt, ich habe ja noch gar keinen neuen Job.
Ich schreibe eine Skillliste für den vermeintlichen neuen Job.
Wie gesagt, also ich erzähle es jetzt nochmal, weil jetzt sind die ganzen Leute da.
Ich habe noch letztens ein Video hochgeladen auf YouTube,
wo ich gesagt habe, hier Ende des Jahres ist wahrscheinlich Schluss.
Hast du Azure-Zentriffe? Ich habe Azure-Schulungen, ja.
Die können wir hinschreiben, tatsächlich.
So, ich habe noch dieses Video hochgeladen und nachdem ich das Video hochgeladen habe,
zwei Minuten später, hatte ich eine Mail von einem Ex-Arbeitskollege,
hat gemeint, Max, willst du nicht bei uns anfangen?
Ich habe gesagt, ja, klingt ja nicht schlecht.
Dann hat er mir das versucht, ein bisschen schmackhaft zu machen und hat mir gedacht,
meine Güte, der Kerl ist aber motiviert.
War er bei uns ja gar nicht, so.
Und daher geht er übelst ab.
Und habe ich gesagt, klingt wirklich nicht schlecht.
Was, was, was wollen, was wollen wir jetzt machen?
Da meint er, ja, ab November, können wir, können wir uns das dann überlegen.
Und ich soll ihm mal Lebenslauf und so Skillliste schicken,
Anschreiben und Gedöns, können wir uns sparen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt Runde ecknen.
Dass er eine Provision kann sein, soll mir, soll mir recht sein.
Was ist das?
Ein Latex-Template.
Oh, ich weiß, geben soll.
Ups, falsch.
Gibt es, gibt es sinnvolle Zertifikate oder Workshops?
Na ja, es gibt sinnvolle Workshops bzw. sinnvolle Kurse, die man machen kann bestimmt.
Aber sinnvolle Zertifikate kommt drauf an, wie sehr die da drauf stehen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich bin jetzt nicht so der große Zertifikats-Fan.
Das passt schon.
Wie gesagt.
Der eine kennt mich ja schon und der war schon bei seinem, also es muss so gewesen sein.
Der hat das Video gesehen, hat mich angeschrieben, hat mir das schmackhaft gemacht,
hat gefragt, ob ich will.
Er hat gesagt, ja, will ich.
Klingt gut.
Und dann hat er zu mir gemeint, ja, schick mal, dann hat er gesagt,
ich frag mal, ich frag mal meinen, meinen Chef oder den,
ich frag mal den Personaltyp oder so.
Keine Ahnung, was er genau gesagt hat.
Und der meinte so irgendwie, ja, schaff, schaff her die Leute.
Und Tag später hat er mir geschrieben, schick mal Lebenslauf und Skillliste.
Ja, mach ich.
Ja, wie gesagt, könnte gut sein.
Leute, wenn ich irgendwas übersehe, schreibt da Ed Wubblos dabei.
Naja, was heißt Vitamin B?
Vitamin B wäre ja, wenn ich explizit jetzt einen anschreibe,
so nach dem Motto, ich will dahin.
Kannst mal ein gutes Wort für mich einlegen.
Das war eher umgedreht, so nach dem Motto.
Ach, ich habe ein Video von Max gesehen.
Lass den doch mal anschreiben.
So, okay, weiter, weiter.
Sonst wird das heute nichts, Leute.
GitHub Actions.
Jenkins.
Können wir tatsächlich auch mal reinschreiben.
Warum nicht?
GitLab.
Bitbucket.
Docker.
Post.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ansible.
Terraform.
Pulumi.
Keine Ahnung.
Jaira.
Na, das ist im Enterprise-Umfeld jetzt nicht so relevant.
C-Mail.
Oh Gott.
Ganz davon abgesehen von Maple und Cradle habe ich auch keine Ahnung.
Monitoring Tools.
Ah ja, das ist gut.
Mal gucken, was ich mit den Sachen denn mache, die da drin stehen.
Ja, Monitoring Tools ist sehr gute Idee, Leute.
Prometheus.
Grafana.
Subbix.
Nagios.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, aber Leute, ich mache das schon seit 15 Jahren.
Syslog.
Syslog ist kein...
Ja, das schreiben wir bei Linux hin.
Ja, Syslog, Datenbank habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ja, Broggers Zeug machen wir dann gleich.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz gucken, dass ich das ein bisschen...
Waren wir mal Cloud-Gedöns noch?
Alerting.
Bash.
Ja.
Soft Skills habe ich keine.
Ich kann gute Technik, aber ansonsten bin ich...
Mag ich, hasse ich alle anderen Menschen.
Scrum.
Ja.
Also, wenn ich nicht mindestens 5 Dailys am Tag habe, fühle ich mich naggisch.
Aber wenn man für Graffer, du meinst Influx DB oder was?
Kann man mal reinschreiben, ja.
Ja.
PromQL.
Ja, gut, das ist ja Prometheus.
Icinga.
Da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Was ist Icinga?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Aber ich weiß, dass die das da benutzen.
Aber das schreibe ich nicht hin.
Weil da fragen die mich was zu, wenn die das benutzen und Ahnung davon haben.
Oder ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich fake da jetzt auch nichts.
Was?
Icinga.
Ja.
Das muss ich irgendwie zusammenfassen.
So wie übliche Tools, irgendwie sowas, ja, weiß nicht, bla bla, keine Ahnung, dass man
da alles hinschreiben kann.
Proxmox, ne, das habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Äh, machen wir mal Cloud, machen wir mal Cloud Geschichten.
CD, naja, komm.
Hast du Tipps für einen, ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen hoch machen, dass ich ein bisschen
was sehe hier.
Hast du Tipps für einen C Sharp Software Entwickler?
Du meinst, sorry Leute, C Lattenshauen, einen C Lattenshauen Software Entwickler, der nach
Ausbildung zweier Berufserfahrungen hat, Unternehmen gar nicht verweigert.
Ja, dich woanders bewerben.
Oder aber die haben irgendeinen Grund, den du nachvollziehen kannst.
Aber wenn es der übliche Grund ist, so nach dem Motto, ah, aktuell ist die wirtschaftliche
Lage so schlecht.
Oder manche erzählen, ha, du musst doch erstmal was, du musst doch erstmal so in Vorleistung,
du musst doch erstmal was zeigen oder was auch immer.
Da wird so viel Bullshit gelabert.
So nach dem Motto, man feiert sich permanent ab, jedes Jahr ist das erfolgreichste Jahr,
aber den Leuten will man nichts geben.
Das einfachste, was du machen kannst, ist wirklich nicht woanders bewerben.
Fähige Programmierer werden gesucht, wirklich überall.
Serverless, oh Serverless ist auch richtig, richtig high IQ.
Serverless, ok, also, ok, dann muss ich, cloud, cloud, ok, also Azure, kenne ich mich eigentlich
mit Abstand am besten aus, also von diesen Enterprise Dingern.
Moin, nee guck mal, nee, das habe ich jetzt gar nicht den Wahnsinnsplan von.
Deswegen, normalerweise, wenn man da jetzt hinter schreibt, gut, schlecht, Profi oder
so, würde ich, würde ich, guck mal, nee, das bei Einsteiger oder so hinschreiben.
Ist ja nicht, dass ich da einen wahnsinnskrassen Plan von hätte.
Ja, ich kann da was deployen, ich kann da was starten, aber so irgendwie Cluster from
scratch für sonst was aufbauen, high availability, gedönst, ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte
ich da schon so viel mit gemacht.
Wie viel verlangen nach zwei Jahren Berufserfahrung als Werkstudent Java Entwickler pro Stunde?
Ja, kommt drauf an, wo, in welcher Branche, wo, in welchem, in welchem, welche Bundesland,
welche Ecke, was kriegst du denn aktuell?
Also, je nachdem, wo du bist, 50, 50 bis, keine Ahnung, 13, hast du, wie 13, das ist
ja unter Mindestlohn, das kann ja nicht sein.
Ach, 13 Euro pro Stunde, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie viel das im Jahr ist, du musst mir sagen,
was das im Jahr ist.
Also, keine Ahnung, 50, 50k oder so, das kann natürlich auch deutlich mehr sein, aber 50
klar, so als Berufseinsteiger, wobei nach zwei Jahren bist du kein Einsteiger mehr, aber
50, 50k, so ohne, dass ich jetzt was weiß über dich, was du machen willst, welche Branche,
wo.
Ach so, das hätte ich vielleicht auch mal lesen sollen, ich hab nur bis hierhin gelesen,
nach zwei Jahren Berufserfahrung, bist du jetzt fertig studieren, also du bist fertig studieren
und bist jetzt quasi Berufseinsteiger, seh ich das richtig, ach noch nicht, ja ok, dann
weiß ichs nicht, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, da hab ich wirklich gar keinen Plan von, das
weiß ich nicht, komm doch auf den Laden dann, naja, also, es gibt ja sogar Untersuchungen
dazu, frag mich jetzt nicht, wie das heißt, aber es gibt ja sogar Studien dazu, dass Leute,
die von einem Themengebiet keine Ahnung haben, dazu neigen, quasi ihre Fähigkeiten maßlos
zu überschätzen, so nach dem Motto, also die ein bisschen Ahnung haben, so rum, also Leute,
die ein bisschen Ahnung haben, nein, nein, nein, das ist was anderes, das ist was anderes,
das ist was anderes, ne, ne, dass Leute ein bisschen Ahnung haben, quasi dazu neigen,
ihre Fähigkeiten deutlich höher einzuschätzen und Leute, die viel Ahnung haben, realistischer,
oftmals eher so nach diesem Motto, es gibt so viel, was ich nicht weiß, ne, ne, ne, ne,
das ist ja eher so ein Pseudowissenschaftsding, ich mein wirklich, was untersucht wurde, also,
ich mein, wenn du das schon so, wenn du das jetzt seit einer Weile machst, ich mein ganz
so schlecht kannst du nicht sein, wenn du da Sachen auf die Reihe bekommst, also da würd
ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken machen, ich mein, ich kenn dich nicht, ich weiß nicht,
was ihr für Projekte macht, es ist schwer zu sagen, ich kenn den Laden nicht, ich weiß
halt nicht, was du machst, ich setz auch nicht, als hätt ich da wahnsinnig viel planen von,
im IE-Bereich hier, wie viel kriegst du denn im Jahr, was ist denn das im Jahr, ist das
mal, ok, 3600, gehen wir mal im besten Fall von aus, du kriegst 14 Monatsgelder, das wäre
ganz ok, je nach, je nach Bundesland, Region und, ja, Erfahrung, und das find ich fast schon
ein bissl wenig, nach zwei Jahren, oder wie lang auch immer du schon Erfahrung hast,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab wirklich keinen Plan, ne, ne, ne, das mein ich nicht, es geht
ums Gehalt vom Chat, ja, sozusagen, so, also weiter, weiter, Cloud, Cloud, Azure, Hetzner,
schreib ich jetzt einfach mal ne bei, ja, haben wir Ahnung von, Digital Ocean, hab
ich tatsächlich früher auch recht viel gemacht, Google Cloud, ja gut, ehrlich gesagt, kenn
ich mich da nur mit Google Maps bissl aus, kann man mal reinschreiben, warum nicht, so,
Serverless, Azure Functions, ja ok, jetzt ist die Frage, was hab ich denn schon für
Azure Schulungen gemacht, interessiert das irgendjemand, scheiß drauf, ich hab irgendwie
so drei Azure Schulungen gemacht, die waren richtig mies, ok, 12,5, komm mal gucken was
ist denn das im Jahr, naja, ich weiß ja nicht wieviel Berufserfahrung du schon insgesamt
schon hast, aber, ich mein, das ist jetzt nicht absolut super, super wenig, aber, Busy
Mare würde ich schon sagen, sollte es da sein, wie sehr bist du in SubX, mittlerweile kenne
ich mich ganz gut in SubX aus, also Busy Mare soll es schon sein denke ich, als, als,
hier 45k, ich mein, Leute, ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das erzählt hab, aber, ich hab
angefangen, vor, ich weiß gar nicht wann das war, vor 13 Jahren, ich hab angefangen
nach der Ausbildung vor 13 Jahren, so, mit, bei diesem Kack Provider, wo ich damals gearbeitet
hab, als quasi Junior Admin, hab ich angefangen mit 33,6, so, und ich war damals schon nicht
so wahnsinnig zufrieden, ok, 33,6, heißt im Endeffekt, das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal,
15 Jahre spät, Turnschuh Admin, ja, sagen wir mal, das ist 15 Jahre später, dann ist,
naja, also das dürfte schon ein Busy Mare sein, zumal du ja nicht Einsteiger bist, sondern
auch schon was gemacht hast, also, aber, wie du auf jeden Fall mehr Geld bekommst ist,
dich umzugucken, was es sonst noch so gibt, und dann legst du das denen im Zweifelsfall
auf den Tisch und sagst, hier, guck mal, ich hab ein anderes Angebot, wenn das spruchreif
ist, ansonsten bin ich weg, und, tja, entweder machen sie es oder du gehst zu den anderen,
wo du mehr verdienst und wahrscheinlich sogar glücklicher wirst danach, deswegen, Leute,
also aktuell, es werden IT-Fachkräfte gesucht, wirklich an allen Ecken und Enden, und eigentlich
können sich das die meisten Unternehmen, ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist, die meisten
Unternehmen können sich das eigentlich nur noch erlauben, so wenig zu bezahlen, bzw.
so wenig und dann noch so, und dann noch die Leute gleichzeitig abzufacken, die können
sich das nur erlauben, weil die meisten Leute wie ich sind und viel zu faul, faul in der
Richtung, sich was Neues zu suchen. Da muss immer erst eine gewisse Schmerzgrenze überschritten
sein, dass die aktiv werden. So, und gerade umso länger man wo ist, umso höher ist diese
Schmerzgrenze irgendwie, zumal man sich an die Läden auch schon gewöhnt hat und eigentlich
keinen Bock auf was anderes hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die XY-Theorie ist, keine Ahnung,
das hab ich mir gerade so überlegt, wenn es seine Theorie zugibt, kann er schon mal
nicht so verkehrt sein, was ich mir gerade überlegt hab. Also, das heißt, das beste,
was man machen kann, ist wirklich zu gucken, was es sonst noch so gibt. Das heißt ja nicht
mal, dass du wechseln musst. Du kannst ja immer noch sagen, ne ist nicht, aber zumindest
gucken, was es noch gibt. Und ich wette mit euch, in ein paar Jahren, wenn das mit der
Fachkräfte so weitergeht, sind die Gehälter bei 5-stellig, äh 6-stellig. Das wird richtig,
also erstens ist Inflationsrate abfakt, die müssen mehr werden, und IT ist, also IT immer
mit der Prämisse, die Leute können ein bisschen was. Den 0-15-Windows-Clicker, den braucht
auch keiner. Da brauchst du vielleicht ein paar davon, aber auch keine Horden. Aber Leute,
die Ahnung haben von ihrem Gebiet, und den die nur schwätzen, da gibt es ja auch nicht
so viel. Aber nachher mal gucken. Und, insofern, die müssen in die Tasche greifen.
Das hat er, naja, wenn der das so sieht, dann hat er ja anscheinend genug Leute und hat
ein riesen Pool, aus dem er sich das aussuchen kann. Was wahrscheinlich nicht so ist. Aber
ganz im Ernst, dann scheiß drauf. Das ist doch nur Angst gemacht. Hast du es schon mal
wirklich erlebt oder erzählen die das nur? Weil das kann auch ein bisschen Angstgemache
sein, dass die Leute erst gar nicht anfangen, sich was anderes anzugucken. Also ich hab
beim letzten Gespräch mit meinem Chef klar gesagt, zumal er weiß, dass ich ja nicht
zufrieden bin mit der aktuellen Situation. Und ich hab dem auch klar gesagt, ich gucke
gerade nach was anderem. Ich hab ihm sogar erzählt, ich hatte schon einen Probearbeitstag.
Gut, dass das jetzt am Ende nichts geworden ist. Da ist ja was anderes, ein anderes Thema.
Da hat er sogar gesagt, versteht er. Er weiß, dass ich nicht zufrieden bin. Aber, ich mein,
deswegen ist es ja nicht schlechter, was ich arbeite da. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
wenn die mich wirklich kicken würden, was sie gar nicht könnten, so ohne weiter. Also
wenn die es wirklich machen würden, wäre ich sogar froh, dann hätte ich nicht so lange
Kündigungsfristen. Schonmal was mit Rust gemacht. Ja, Blazing lief fast. Wir waren in 5 Minuten
fertig, weil es Rust ist. Hä, warum? Warum? Du musst ja, es ist doch immer eine Frage dessen,
wie man das macht. Es ist doch immer eine Frage, wie man das macht. Also, wenn du sagst
hier, ich bin da und damit nicht zufrieden, und dann sagt man dir, ja, können wir jetzt
gerade nichts machen und du guckst dich anderweitig um, was vergiftet das, die Arbeitsatmosphäre.
Ich mein, du bist nicht zufrieden und du machst was dagegen. Ich weiß nicht, was daran jetzt
irgendwie verwerflich sein soll. Ich mein, die könnten alternativ ja auch sagen, gut,
kommen wir dir ein bisschen entgegen. Wir können vielleicht nicht alles erfüllen, aber zumindest
vielleicht ein bisschen. Ich mein, es reicht doch auch schon, wenn man nicht einfach nur
grundsätzlich sagt, nee, du kriegst nichts, sondern zum Beispiel sagen könnte, ja, also
aktuell aus diesen und diesen Gründen ist das gerade nicht möglich, aber wir machen
mal einen Plan, so wie das für die Perspektive die nächsten 1-2 Jahre aussieht, aber dann
auch dementsprechend mit gewisser Sicherheit. Irgendwas, man kann doch viel mehr machen,
als einfach nur sagen, nö, gibt's nicht. Und wenn man das sagt, dann muss man sich doch
nicht wundern, wenn die Leute woanders gucken. Außerdem, warum sollte man nicht mehr da arbeiten
wollen? Also ich find's prinzipiell gar nicht mal so übel, gerade weil ich die Leute mag,
wo ich bin, aber ich bin mit vielen Sachen nicht zufrieden. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass
ich da irgendwie, dass da, weiß ich, in Zusammenhang kann ich gar nicht herstellen, warum es das
da irgendwie schlechter machen sollte. Du hast doch garantiert keine Vereinbarung, natürlich
hab ich Königungsfristen. Ich hab sogar relativ lange. Ich hab, pass mal auf, ich weiß gar
nicht, ob ich im Detail erzählen darf, aber so mal grob, ich hab mindestens 3 Monate.
Geht's bei dir nur um die Homeoffice-Sache, oder warum willst du wechseln? Also, ok, soll
ich was zu erzählen, Leute? Ich mein, eigentlich muss ich meine Skill-Liste fertig machen,
aber wenn ich davon anfange, das dauert bestimmt 10 Minuten, bis ich da jetzt was erzählt hab.
Also, ich bleib mal kurz im Chat da oben, dass ich das jetzt nicht vergesse. Ok, ich
bleib mal kurz im Chat. Also, geht's bei dir jetzt nur um die Homeoffice-Sache, oder warum
willst du wechseln? Es geht tatsächlich um mehr als die Homeoffice-Sache. Du kannst nicht
schlechter als die gesetzlichen Königungsfristen haben. Nee, was ist schlechter? Länger? Wie
gesagt, ich hab mindestens 3 Monate. Es sind mehr, ich weiß, dass es mehr sind, aber ich
sag euch nicht, wie viel es genau ist. Also, es ist noch mehr. Es ist natürlich hauptsächlich
die Homeoffice-Thematik. Sicher, dass du die Königungsfrist hast, nicht der Arbeitgeber?
Ziemlich sicher, ja. Naja, also, es geht um mehr als Homeoffice. Es ist hauptsächlich
die Homeoffice-Thematik, die mir auf den Keks geht, aber die geht mir aus mehreren Gründen
auf den Keks, die Homeoffice-Thematik. Das Erste ist, es hat wunderbar funktioniert,
weil Corona war die letzten paar Jahre über und davor auch schon. Es ist nicht so, als
hätte man davor nicht auch schon, zwar nicht so viel wie bei Corona, aber nicht davor
auch schon Homeoffice gemacht. Es hat wunderbar funktioniert, es ist für alle Beteiligten
besser, ja, sowohl von der Arbeit her, also für den Arbeitnehmer als auch für den Arbeitgeber
muss ich jetzt nicht wieder die große Leier rausholen. Das heißt, ich kann nicht verstehen,
warum sie überhaupt anfangen jetzt mit, die Leute sollen wieder zurück. Dann, ich arbeite
Teilzeit und soll genauso oft vor Ort sein, wie jemand der Vollzeit arbeitet. Auch mega
abfuck, habe ich auch schon in vielen Stellen gesagt. Das ist auch was, was mir ziemlich
auf den Keks geht. Dann, dass es keine ersichtlichen Begründungen irgendwie gibt, warum man sich
jetzt auf einmal 180 Grad gedreht hat, denn mitten in Corona wurde groß verkündet, es
gibt jetzt eine offizielle Homeoffice-Regelung und die offizielle Homeoffice-Regelung sah
so aus, dass man mit seinem direkten Vorgesetzten das abmachen kann. Da gab sogar so ein Formular,
was rumgeschickt wurde, das konnte man ausfüllen und dann sollte man das mit seinem direkten
Vorgesetzten klären können, wie viele Tage die Woche Homeoffice. Und damals hatte ich
mit meinem Chef ausgemacht, dass ich 4 Tage, äh, nicht 4 Tage, 3 Tage Homeoffice mache
und 1 Tag auf die Arbeit komme. So, ich habe dieses Formular nie wieder gesehen. Das habe
ich abgegeben, das habe ich eingereicht, das hieß, das dauert jetzt kurz, es kam nie wieder
was. Warum kam nie wieder was? Meine persönliche Vermutung jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Wahrscheinlich haben die festgestellt, oh Mist, das wollen ja auf einmal ganz viele machen.
Wahrscheinlich haben die vorher wieder komplett lost auf ihrer Management-Ebene gedacht, das
will doch keiner machen, weil das ist auch so ein Punkt, dass in vielen Punkten unser
Management extrem, also wirklich extrem detached ist von der eigentlichen Realität, ja. Und
ich meine damit nicht, dass die irgendwie eine Vision haben oder so nach dem Motto, ja,
so soll es da hingehen, sondern dass es komplett andere Ansichten gibt quasi. Was heißt andere
Ansichten? Das stimmt, das stimmt nicht. Es geht ja da nicht um Ansichten. Dass die Sachen
nicht so gesehen werden, wie sie sind, ja. Und das auch nicht wissen will, oder irgendwie,
keine Ahnung. Zumindest ist es äußerst ziemlich entkoppelt von dem an vielen Stellen, wie
es wirklich ist. Wahrscheinlich haben sie wieder festgestellt, oh, das machen ja tatsächlich
jetzt ganz viele und jetzt wollen sie nicht. Also sprich, erst haben sie so was Offizielles
gemacht und jetzt, anstatt es zuzugeben, okay, wir haben uns da vielleicht ein bisschen verkalkuliert,
hat man einfach nie wieder was von diesen Anträgen gehört. So, und das ist schon ziemlich
beschissen. Kannst du nicht einfach nichts mehr sagen danach. So, also das ist die ganze
Home Office Thematik. Da hängt noch ein bisschen mehr dran. Es ist halt da in der Form für
ein Arsch. Ich weiß, dass ganz viele bei uns das Problem haben. Wir haben sogar ein,
das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, wir haben sogar ein Risikopatient ist es ja nicht, weil
der hat ja gerade kein Corona. Ein Risikogruppenangehörigen, also er gehört einer Risikogruppe an. Das hat
er auch vom Arzt als Attest und sonst wie was. Der hat Immunerkrankungen, also für
den wäre Corona wirklich richtig beschissen. Und der hat jetzt seit Corona quasi Dauer
Home Office gemacht. Und jetzt kam ernsthaft allen Ernstes jemand zu ihm und meinte, er
soll doch mal wieder ins Büro gehen. Da hat er gesagt, Leute, ich bin Risikogruppe, ich
bringe mich doch nicht um, wenn ich hier nach Frankfurt fahre. Wir haben Inzidenzwert von
Waffei 970. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, das würde doch eigentlich alles nur während
dem Lockdown gelten. Aktuell gibt es ja keine rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen. Er soll doch
wieder mindestens so und so viele Tage vor Ort kommen. Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe,
also spätestens wenn es darum geht, dass man wissendlich in Kauf nimmt, dass jemand stirbt.
Und das ist jetzt bei Immunerkrankungen tatsächlich, je nachdem, wie stark der Verlauf ist, gar
nicht so weit von einem realistischen Szenario entfernt. Das muss halt nicht sein.
Das finde ich auch schon mal beschissen, aber das ist die ganze Home Office Thematik. Der
Rest ist halt so übliche Sachen, die mir schon lange auf den Keks gehen. Zum Beispiel,
wie gesagt, dass das Management an vielen Stellen total entkoppelt ist von der Realität,
dass man permanent sagt, es muss alles hinterfragt werden und hier verbessern und da verbessern
und hier Vorschläge machen. Und das Problem ist, ich bin jetzt da schon eine Weile dabei.
Ich habe so viele Vorschläge gemacht, mich auch an so vielen Dingen beteiligt. Es ist
nichts rausgekommen, niemals. Dieser Laden möchte sich nicht verbessern. Die möchten
nur das Prestige haben, quasi nach außen hin zu sagen, guckt hier, wir verbessern uns
und wir machen ganz viel, aber innerlich wollen sie das gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr
das kennt, das ist so ein ganz komisches Phänomen. Man möchte an ganz vielen Stellen natürlich
so das supermoderne Unternehmen von Welt geben und auch gerne dieses Image haben, aber man
möchte nicht das machen im Kern, was man eigentlich machen müsste, damit das der Wahrheit
entspreche. Und das ist halt auch das Dove, dass auf der einen Seite so getan wird, als
wäre das so, aber dann, wenn die Entscheidungen getroffen werden müssen, dass es so wird,
wird es dann absichtlich nicht gemacht. Dann gibt es dann solche Sachen wie, wir wissen
um unsere Schwächen und sowas. Da war keine Aussage, wir wissen um unsere Schwächen. Das
ist auch geil. Wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht, zu geile Story, ich weiß Recycle Story, aber
wahrscheinlich haben die noch nicht alle gehört. Wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht, da war
sogar jemand vom TÜV damals da, der diese Umfrage gemacht hat. Das sollte dann ein
bisschen den Anschein haben, es ist quasi was von außen und was offizielles und so,
was nicht von uns gefakt ist. Dann wurde diese Umfrage gemacht, wie zufrieden sind sie mit
ihrem Aufgabenfeld, wie klar sind Aufgaben gestellt und solche Geschichten kam in der
Umfrage drin vor und da wurden die Umfrageergebnisse vorgestellt und natürlich war das ein sehr
gutes Ergebnis, natürlich, natürlich. So, aber wenn man sich die Noten mal angeguckt
hat, so gut waren die Noten gar nicht. Die beste Note war glaube ich in 2,7, es gab irgendwie
acht Kategorien oder so und in der Kategorie, die Frage war sinngemäß sowas wie irgendwie
ihre täglichen oder ihr Aufgabengebiet, wie klar sind Aufträge formuliert und da konntest
du bewerten, so total unklar, superklar und da hatten wir glaube ich sogar eine 4,7 oder
ne, auf jeden Fall schlechter als 4,2 oder so Note insgesamt und ich glaube sogar schon
abgerundet auf 5, wahrscheinlich war es dann 4,5 oder so, es war richtig schlecht. So und
jetzt kommt der Hit, also die Noten waren insgesamt gar nicht so geil und das ist schon
ne Weile her, das ist die letzten Jahre nicht besser geworden. So, also die Noten waren
gar nicht so geil, ok und was macht man jetzt, anstatt zu sagen und das ist genau so ein
Beispiel für das was ich meine, was mir bei der Firma auf den Keks geht, anstatt jetzt
zu sagen, oh das Ergebnis ist ja gar nicht so wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben, weil
also die Selbstdarstellung in der Management-Ebene war natürlich, wir haben überall Einser oder
auch so diese Selbstwahrnehmung, wir haben bestimmt überall Einser. So und jetzt gibt
es und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt, entweder hätte man sagen können, oh Mist, das ist
ja gar nicht so gut wie wir uns das gedacht haben, wie können wir denn die Punkte verbessern?
Und nicht nur irgendwelche hohlen Phrasen, sondern was können wir wirklich konkret
machen? Es gibt ja durchaus offensichtliche Punkte auch bei dieser Umfrage, die rausgekommen
sind, die man machen könnte. So, aber nein, dazu hat man sich nicht entschieden, man hat
sich dafür entschieden das schlechte Ergebnis als sehr gutes Ergebnis darzustellen und wisst
ihr wie man das gemacht hat? Jetzt kommt der Six-Hand-Move aller Zeiten, den müsst ihr
euch merken Leute, wenn ihr mal ein schlechtes Ergebnis habt und ne, Beidstreichs gefälscht
waren die nicht wirklich, müsst ihr euch merken, wenn ihr mal ein schlechtes Ergebnis gut darstellen
wollt. Also man nimmt einfach nicht die Noten als reine Zahlen, sondern man nimmt die als
Vergleichswerte. Also ihr könnt davon ausgehen, der TÜV hat schon tausende dieser Umfragen
gemacht, das heißt die haben relativ viel Vergleichsdatensätze und dann haben die sich
einen Vergleichsdatensatz rausgesucht, der noch schlechter war als wir und haben dann
links den Vergleichsdatensatz angezeigt und rechts unsere, unsere Sachen, ohne zu sehr
auf die Noten einzugehen. So, dann hatten wir dann beispielsweise ne 2,7 bei dem einen
Punkt und der andere hatte ne 3,9. Und dann hat man gesehen, alter sind wir gut, die Noten
waren immer noch ziemlich beschissen, aber im Vergleich zum Vergleichsdatensatz waren
wir natürlich wahnsinnig gut. Und dann hat man wieder auch große, große Töne gespuckt
so nach dem Motto, ein sehr gutes Ergebnis. Es ist halt, das könnte man glaube ich zusammenfassen,
es ist halt sehr viel mehr Schein als Sein, das ist auch was, was mich ziemlich stört.
So, das deckt sich dann auch mit so unverlässlichen Aussagen, du kannst dich ja prinzipiell auf
keinerlei Management Aussage wirklich verlassen, deswegen schreibe ich mir mittlerweile, deswegen
habe ich mittlerweile mein, mein Konter, Kontertextdokument, wenn mal wieder irgend einer was behauptet
was nicht stimmt. Ja, zum Beispiel wurde bei uns auch gesagt, ja, Service XY wird jetzt
in die Cloud umgezogen, ging es um einen konkreten Service, Service XY wird jetzt in die Cloud
umgezogen und das muss innerhalb von einem halben Jahr alles passieren. Und, dass Teile
des Services schwierig umzuziehen sind, ist keine Ausrede dafür es nicht umzuziehen.
Okay, das war so die ursprüngliche Ansage. Achso, ja und das Wichtigste habe ich noch
ganz vergessen. Und die Aussage, die noch dazu kam, Probleme, die durch den Cloud Umzug
auftreten, werden in Kauf genommen. So, da wurde das ganze Ding in die Cloud umgezogen,
unter anderem auch alle Teilservices, wo man gleich gesagt hat, Leute, so wie das jetzt
hier geplant ist, könnte das problematisch werden. Und was ist passiert? Naja, es gab
irgendwie eineinhalb Tage Ausfall für diesen Service. Und da war natürlich die Kacke am
dampfen. So, und meint ihr, es hat sich noch jemand dran erinnert, dass die Sachen in Kauf
genommen werden? Ne, natürlich nicht. Man hat sich darüber aufgeregt, dass den Leuten,
die daran beteiligt waren, ja anscheinend gar nicht klar gewesen wäre, was das bedeutet.
Also, das ist auch so was, wo komplett, ich hatte damit zum Glück noch am Rande zu tun,
das ist auch wie so komplette Entkopplung zur Realität, ja. So, dann ist es noch ein
weiterer Punkt und ich muss langsam mal gut sagen, dass aber noch ein weiterer Punkt ist,
dass wir sehr viele Manager haben, die nicht managen, wo ich nicht genau weiß, was sie
machen, aber sie managen auf jeden Fall nicht. Normalerweise solltest du Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter
und sonst wie, also die Leute, die quasi über dir sind, die sollten ja unter anderem dafür
da sein, organisatorische Sachen zu erledigen. Ja, oder klare, sagen wir nicht mal organisatorische
Sachen zu erledigen, das macht ja mein Chef, so ist es ja nicht, aber organisatorische
Rahmenbedingungen quasi auch vorzugeben, ja, wie was sein soll, sodass das halt auch Gruppen-
und Abteilungsübergreifung besser funktionieren. Das Problem ist, und das macht bei uns niemand,
ich weiß nicht, was die machen, sind sie anscheinend sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt,
aber im Endeffekt läuft es darauf raus, dass du in vielen Punkten Technik und Organisation
nun selbst machen musst, weil es keiner macht, obwohl es eigentlich nicht dein Job ist. Und
ich an vielen Stellen schon mir gedacht habe, Leute, das mache ich jetzt nicht, das ist
überhaupt nicht mein Job. Und du kannst quasi dir schon zugucken, dass es dann gegen die
Wand fährt. Zum Beispiel eine meiner Lieblingsdiskussionen war, da war ich auf unserer Change-Runde,
also wir haben einmal in der Woche so ein Event, wo alle Changes angekündigt werden, da war
ich bei uns auf unserer Change-Runde und wir sind relativ groß Random Win. So, und da war
ich auf einer Change-Runde und ich habe was angekündigt, es wollte irgendeiner, fragt
mich nicht, nee, nee, nee, nicht das TSL-Zertifikat, es wollte irgendeiner was upgraden, ich glaube
Elastic Search oder so. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht mal, was es genau war. Habe ich
angekündigt, alles okay, wurde genehmigt in der Change-Runde und dann wurde das abgesagt,
weil es irgendwie zeitliche Probleme gab und dann habe ich das die nächste Woche wieder
vorgestellt und habe ich gesagt, gut, das ist der Change von letzter Woche, der musste
wegen zeitlichen, was weiß ich, blablabla, musste der verschoben werden, ist der gleiche
wie letzte Woche, nur auf diese Woche Donnerstag verschoben und da habe ich mir halt so gedacht,
gut, das wird jetzt genehmigt, kein Ding und auf einmal kommt einer unserer, dieser Leute,
die eigentlich fürs Koordinieren zuständig sind und meint, ja, wurde das und das und
das beachtet. Habe ich gesagt, das habe ich doch letzte Woche alles schon erzählt, außerdem
steht das im Ticket drin, außerdem hat das damit gar nichts zu tun. Ja, das muss er sich
aber noch ein bisschen genauer angucken und derjenige, der die Changes macht, soll doch
mal dafür sorgen, dass wenn er den Change macht, nachts noch jemand zum Entstören da
ist. Da habe ich ihm auch gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne, das muss der nicht machen, weil der
macht keine Personalplanung, wir machen keine Personalplanung für Nacht-Einsätze und da
meint, doch, in dem Fall, sollen die sich da drum kümmern, habe ich ihm auch gesagt,
du bist doch Koordinator, dann koordiniere doch und dann meinte der ernsthaft zu mir,
ne, so einfach geht das nicht, dann müsst ihr zu mir kommen und das beauftragen, dass
ich mich drum kümmere. Ich beauftrag gar nichts, du bist Koordinator, wir sind in der Koordinationsrunde,
du hast das gehört und da musste dann schon unser Moderator einspringen, hat gesagt,
jaja, das können wir später klären, so nach dem Motto, das ist ja auch geil, da hat mich
danach wirklich nochmal unser Change Management angeschrieben, hat gemeint, das hat er noch
nie gehört, ein Koordinator, der nix koordinieren will, das ist schon mittlerweile Running Gag
bei uns, aber was ich in dem Fall tatsächlich gut fand, es wurde danach nochmal offiziell
klargestellt, dass es nicht unsere Aufgabe ist, uns um solche Sachen zu kümmern, ich habe damit
prinzipiell gar keine Schmerzen, solche Sachen ab und zu mal sich mit drum zu kümmern, aber nicht,
wenn man dafür explizit Leute hat, die dabei sind und sagen, sie wollen sich nicht um ihre
Sachen kümmern, wofür sie eigentlich da sind, es gibt viele Sachen bei uns, wo ich mir denke,
what the fuck, Alter, der übliche Business Enterprise Umfeld Wahnsinn, ne, die haben das
nicht geguckt, bin so überfordert, was ich nach der Physi-Ausbildung mache, man kann ja nichts
wirklich alles nur angekratzt, das liegt aber auch daran, also es liegt auch ein bisschen an dir,
also du musst dich ja auch schon mit Sachen beschäftigen in der Ausbildung, also man kann
in der Ausbildung nicht darauf hoffen, dass man durch Berufsschule und Betrieb alles beigebracht
kriegt, was man für immer braucht, ja, also ein bisschen sich selbst was angucken muss man schon
und dann findet man doch eigentlich die Themengebiete, die einem am meisten gefallen.
Berufsschule ist eh für'n Arsch, so ich scroll jetzt hier drüber, ich glaube,
das ist ziemlich normal, was ich gerade erzählt habe in vielen größeren Läden, aber wenn ich
irgendwas übersehe, Leute, schreibt es doch mal in den Chat, ich scroll jetzt drüber,
dass wir weitermachen können, hast du, nein, ich hab nicht studiert, spielt für dich die größte
der Firma eine Rolle, Startup vs. Meo, eigentlich weniger, hab ja auch so tolle Firmen, Leute,
wir sind die Meister im Selbstabfeiern, ich hab noch kein Unternehmen erlebt,
was sich so krass selbst abfeiert, die feiern sich alle selbst ab, aber die sind die Meister
im Selbstfeiern, wir haben auch regelmäßig so Klatschevents, wo dann irgendwelche neuen
Sachen vorgestellt werden und da wird dann erwartet, dass an jedem Satz geklatscht wird,
gehe ich aber mittlerweile aus Prinzip nicht mehr hin, hast du Tipps, wie man sich am besten
ans Bewerben rangeht, bzw., nein, keine Ahnung, du merkst doch selbst, ich hab keine Ahnung,
wie man eine Bewerbung richtig macht, keine Ahnung, naja, da hast du im Zweifelsfall das
Problem, was ich jetzt alles geschildert habe, umso größer und umso mehr Business Enterprise
Boomer Laden, müssen ja nicht alle so sein, aber umso mehr geht es halt in die Richtung,
das ist auch typisch, das ist ja auch so, das kann ich mir bei uns auch wunderbar vorstellen,
ja, genau, also er schreibt, Richard schreibt, bei uns wurden Stellen abgebaut und dann ist
in einer Mail ausgeschrieben worden, dass alle Dienste, die durch die Mitarbeiter, die
das Unternehmen verlassen müssen, nicht weiter, also betreut werden, könnte man sagen, serviert
ist vielleicht, also sprich, die Dienste, die die Mitarbeiter, die entlassen wurden,
betreut haben, sind nicht mal wichtig sozusagen, kann man drauf scheißen, ja, so, nachdem das
dann so der Fall war, ein Tag danach kam schon die erste Mail, ja, das geht nicht, wer betreut
das jetzt, ja, das kann ich mir bei unserem Laden auch wunderbar vorstellen.
Würdest du Zappix als Abschlussprojekt empfehlen?
Ja, aber das darfst du nicht einfach so drauf schreiben, also, nochmal was zum IRK Abschlussprojekt,
auch auf die Gefahr hin, dass ich heute nicht mehr viel war, eh doch, bisschen was müssen
wir da schon noch reinschreiben gleich, also, nochmal zur IRK Abschlussprojekt, es ist
fast egal, was ihr als Abschlussprojekt macht, ihr müsst den, wie sagt man so, den Scope
richtig wählen, also, du darfst nicht reinschreiben, dein Abschlussprojekt ist Installation, Konfiguration
eines Zappix Monitoring Systems oder sowas, das darfst du nicht reinschreiben, das ist
Fail, das wird abgelehnt und wenn es nicht abgelehnt wird, hast du im Zweifelsfall irgendwelche
nervigen Prüfer, das darfst du so nicht machen, was du machen musst ist, wenn du eine Zappix
Installation machen willst, du musst auf deine Abschlussprüfung reinschreiben, Evaluierung
einer, was weiß ich, Enterprise Monitoring Lösung für den Bereich ABC, das musst du
reinschreiben, genau, das was Lithium schreibt, Evaluierung, Einrichtung, Kombination von
Servern, sowas in der Richtung, also, du installierst kein Zappix, du suchst die beste Monitoring
Lösung für das Einsatzgebiet, das kannst du dir alles ausdenken und dann gewinnt halt
zufälligerweise Zappix deine Kriterienmatrix, du machst im Prinzip das, was die IRK sehen
will, nicht was sinnvoll ist, was sinnvoll ist, das gehts überhaupt nicht darum, du machst
das, was die IRK sehen will, die IRK will zum Beispiel eine Produktauswahl sehen, dann
sagst du, ok, ich mach so eine Auswahlmatrix, schreib die Vor- und Nachteile der Produkte
hin, schreib was das ganze kostet, beziehungsweise was man da jetzt schon hat und was man Know-how
braucht und sowas in der Richtung und dann kommst du halt zum Schluss, Zappix ist für
uns das beste und dann machst du so eine kleine Testinstallation, du machst keine fertige,
das ist nämlich viel zu groß für ein Abschlussprojekt, ja, also ein komplettes Monitoring System,
du kannst auch zusammenfaken, was das Zeug hält, ist egal, es muss halbwegs plausibel
sein, also, komplette Monitoring-Lösungen für irgendeine Live-Umgebung hinzustellen
ist überhaupt nichts im Scope eines Abschlussprojekts, Abschlussprojekt ist wie viel, 30 Stunden
oder so, 20 Stunden plus 10 für Doku oder irgendwie, das kannst du vergessen, das kannst
du in der Zeit überhaupt nicht machen, realistisch betrachtet, was du machst ist eine Produktauswahl
und eventuell eine Proof of Concept Testinstallation, das machst du, das mag die IRK, du musst kein
fertiges Monitoring-System für alles hinstellen, du suchst dir aus, Zappix, Nagios, Grafana,
Prometheus und was nennt man, was nennt man noch als für das, irgendein Crap, den keiner
mehr verwendet, Ping, von Hand in der Schleife, Checker im Car, ja genau, ja das ist alles
ein bisschen ähnlich, PRTG, ja nimm PRTG, nimm PRTG, da kannst du gleich schon reinschreiben,
Kriterium, Open Source und Linux lauffähig, fällt PRTG, auch wenn es gar nicht schlecht
ist, sofort raus, aber da hast du schon mal ein Produkt drinne, genau, PRTG, nimm Nagios,
PRTG, Zappix und Prometheus, Grafana, man kann ihn natürlich, man kann auch Grafana
mit Zappix und so, oder nimm einfach nur Prometheus, nimm nur Prometheus und dann schreibst du
bei Prometheus als Negativpunkt, kein eingebautes Dashboard, kein eingebautes Craftzeugs, brauch
Zusatzsoftware und bei Zappix kannst du dann hinschreiben, dass es eine super All in One
Lösung ist mit, denk dir was aus, ich mach jetzt nicht deine Abschlussarbeit, aber so
musst du das machen, ne, wir schreiben eine Skillliste für meine vielleicht zukünftige
Stelle, weil ich sowas brauche, ist das aber nicht eigentlich der Sinn der Ausbildung
und Beruf zu lernen, man arbeitet doch schließlich schon 40 Stunden, das mag vielleicht der Sinn
einer Ausbildung mal früher gewesen sein, dass du nach einer Ausbildung den Job umfänglich
ausüben kannst, aber das ist als Physi auf jeden Fall nicht so, ist nicht so, du lernst,
wenn du Glück hast, das absolute Mindeste, wenn du dich nicht selbst drum kümmerst, aber
du hast dann ziemlich gelitten, also du musst dich während der Ausbildung selbst drum kümmern,
auch in deiner Freizeit musst du dir Sachen, und das ist was, was eigentlich nie aufhört,
du musst dir aktuelle Ereignisse, aktuelle Technologien musst du dir angucken, ich mein,
wie willst du sonst rausfinden, was dir gefällt und was nicht, wenn du nicht gerade Glück
hast, dass du in dem Unternehmen, wo du bist, was machst, was dir von Anfang an super gefällt
und du für immer machen willst, so nach dem Motto, ja für immer ist ja eh so ein Ding,
aber du musst dir ja sogar unterschiedliche Sachen angucken, weil wie willst du sonst
rauskriegen, was das ist, welcher Bereich das ist, was du machen willst, ja, also es
ist ja immer sehr, sehr einseitiger Blickwinkel, was du da im Unternehmen kriegst, das was
dort angesagt ist, was ist deine Lieblingsquelle für IT News, Hacker News, beste, why Combinator
Hacker News, falls man die so ausspricht, jedes Unternehmen feiert sich dort, wie gesagt,
ganz, da wo ich arbeite, ist der Meister der Selbstfeiern.
Was gab's zu Abendessen?
Toastbrot und Frikadellen drauf, die waren noch übrig, pepo fett.
Das wäre was für ein YouTube Video, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, oder?
Okay, ja sowas hier in der Richtung, das klingt doch gut.
Da du schon öfters durchsickern lassen hast, was du auch C-Sharp-Lebbis wolltest, ich
weiß nicht, ob du empfehlen kannst auf Linux Privatentwickler, doch, beste, Vorran, ich
entwickle nur noch, ich entwickle einzig und allein nur noch unter Linux, seit drei Jahren
oder länger, fünf Jahren oder so, nee, am Anfang im Stream habe ich manchmal noch Visual
Studio verwendet, seit vier Jahren oder so, nur noch unter Linux, exklusiv, nichts anderes,
Windows ist bei mir vorbei, ich mache wirklich gar nichts mehr unter Windows, ich muss glücklicherweise
auch keine Windows Desktop Software oder sowas machen, warum das denn, weil Linux für mich
das deutlich angenehmere Betriebssystem zu verwenden ist, gerade wenn es um Technik-Sachen
geht und weil es keine Nachteile mehr gibt, unter Linux.NET zu entwickeln, Visual Studio
ist ok, aber Rider ist besser, aber hier, Rider, beste, kostet was, ist aber wirklich
erschwinglich, kostet 240 Euro im Jahr oder so, das komplette All Desktop Abo, was sind
die Vorteile von Linux, ok, das offensichtlichste ist, ein ordentliches Terminal, ach guck mal,
hier haben wir auch sowas schon mal gemacht, MonkaS, Alter, muss ich mir auch noch mal raus
kopieren, ein ordentliches Terminal und eine ordentliche Shell, das neue Windows Terminal,
das ist zum ersten Mal jetzt ok, das war es aber auch und mit WSL zusammen hat man sogar
eine gescheite Shell, also ein ordentliches Terminal ist schon mal ein großer Pluspunkt,
ein ordentlicher Package Manager ist ein zweiter Pluspunkt und generell fühlt sich halt die
Terminal Bedienung einfach viel besser ins System integriert an, also man merkt unter
Linux eigentlich, dass das ganze GUI Zeug eher obendrauf ist und nicht nebendran, also
ansonsten gibt es ganz viele Sachen, es ist für mich unterm Strich, ich will ja nicht
schlecht reden, der Windows verwendet, um darauf Sachen zu entwickeln, gerade wenn es
Windows Software ist, für mich ist es einfach um Längen angenehmer als unter Windows zu
entwickeln, ja also Ryder unter Linux, beste, jetbrains all desktop und nachdem du ein professional
Hackerman jetzt bist, kannst du dir das hier ja auch kaufen und solltest dir das auch leisten
können, also wenn du mehr machen willst als C-Sharp, kann ich dir wirklich nur wärmstens
das jetbrains all, ja ich will alles, das all products pack empfehlen, so all products
pack koste dich im Jahr 239 Euro und dann wirds immer weniger, so und ich mein ernsthaft
205 Euro im Jahr, ok ab dem dritten Jahr, aber 205 Euro im Jahr ist vollkommen in Ordnung
und die Sachen sind halt auch gut von denen, ja oder Student-Sign, ich glaube du kriegst
mit ner Edu-Adresse bei denen auch ein bisschen günstiger, ja ja hast recht, oder monatlicher,
also die haben wirklich gute Sachen, also ich benutze von denen regelmäßig, nehm mal
gescheite Übersicht, also ich benutze von denen regelmäßig Ryder für C-Sharp, ich
benutze regelmäßig, naja regelmäßig jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber doch ab und zu schon
mal C-Lion, wobei ich da ein letztes Jahr tatsächlich vermehrt wieder Wishful Studio
Code verwende, Go-Land verwende ich auch öfters, ab und zu mal PyCharm und leider nur noch
selten Ruby-Mine, Ruby, beste, also das kann ich dir wirklich nur empfehlen, wenn du, wenn
du professioneller.NET-Entwickler bist, ich entwickel, also ich bin, ich muss ja sagen,
ich verdiene mein Geld nicht mit.NET-Entwicklung, auch wenn sich das vielleicht manchmal mit
den Streaming-Inhalten so aussieht, ja, mach ich nicht, ich benutze das schon ewig, ja
und kenn mich damit auch ganz gut aus, aber ich bin, wenn du es so willst, kein Profi,
wenn man Profi ist, einer der damit Geld verdient, aber ich kann dir wirklich nur empfehlen,
nimm dir das JetBrains All Product Pack und guck dir mal Linux an zum entwickeln, ich
finde das um Längen angenehmer als unter Windows und wenn du Java machen willst, kannst du
JetBrains auch benutzen.
Gibt es eigentlich nur Leute, die Eclipse verwenden, unsere Boomer-Java-Entwickler verwenden
teilweise Eclipse, die anderen verwenden alle IntelliJ.
Na ja, Visual Studio Code finde ich nicht gut für.NET, ganz ehrlich, man kann es
machen, aber ich finde eher vielfaches besser.
ServerEye habe ich noch nie gehört, ja so würde das Projekt heißen.
Moin, wie findest du Ubuntu, das musst du jetzt etwas konkreter sagen und schreib mal
falls du antwortest, Ed Wubblers dabei, dass ich gleich sehe, für was, für Desktop,
für Server, für, keine Ahnung, IOT Geschichten oder Raspberry Pi oder als Media Center oder
was, als was, als Grundlage für was, du kannst ja dein Link in im Chat posten, du meinst
du Peter Aguilé, ja ist so, also zumindest die, die was taugen, ist mir auch schon aufgefallen,
also alle Leute, die ich kenne, die wirklich Plan haben, interessieren sich da auch privat
für, das heißt jetzt nicht, dass du 24-7 nach der Arbeit noch vom Rechner hocken musst,
was ich ja glücklicherweise auch nicht mehr mache, aber ich habe das lange gemacht, bisschen
Bewegung muss sein, aber ansonsten hocke ich vom Rechner, aber ich kann es an der Stelle
wirklich auch nochmal betonen, ihr glaubt gar nicht, ich weiß, hätte ich mir das vor
10 Jahren oder 15 oder gar 20 Jahren gesagt, hätte ich mich selbst ausgekackt, wenn man
schon den ganzen Tag vom Rechner sitzt, es ist wichtig, dass man gescheiten Stuhl hat,
dass man gescheiten Monitor hat und dass es ergonomisch ist, aber es ist durch nichts
zu ersetzen, dass man sich am Tag einfach mal eine Stunde, oder meinetwegen, wenn ihr
gar nicht wollt, eine halbe Stunde, aber es ist eigentlich ein bisschen wenig bewegt,
versucht irgendwie eure 10.000 Schritte am Tag zu machen, ich gehe jeden Tag eineinhalb
bis zwei Stunden ein bisschen wandern hier in der Gegend, manchmal auch zweieinhalb,
je nachdem, wie schön das Wetter ist, jeden Tag, nachdem die Arbeit fertig ist und danach
mache ich Stream, mache ich YouTube oder aber ich mache mir schon während der Sache, wenn
ich durch den Wald laufe oder übers Feld laufe, schon ein bisschen Gedanken, was ich machen
könnte, weil ich bin eigentlich immer zwei Stunden, zwei Stunden weg und irgendwie will
ich ein bisschen bewegen, ich mache keinen krassen Fitnessstudio grind oder so, das muss
nicht sein, aber ein bisschen Bewegung ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt und jedes bisschen
ist besser als gar nichts zu machen, ihr habt weniger Kopfschmerzen, ihr habt weniger Rückenprobleme,
Herz-Kreislauf, ihr habt eigentlich gar keine Probleme mehr, gut, ich meine, seit ihr seid
80 und habt dann wirklich mal Probleme, Stuhlempfehlung fürs Homeoffice, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl,
den würde ich aber nicht empfehlen zu kaufen, zwar der beste Stuhl, den ich kenne, aber
der ist zu teuer, genau das beste, beste News-Seite, ja siehst du, genau, das ist das, was ich
sage Chat, deswegen muss man ein bisschen sich die Sachen angucken, dann merkt man schon,
was einem gefällt, das muss ja auch nicht immer das gleiche sein, es gibt so ein paar
Schwerpunkte, kann nicht jeder alles gleich gut und kann nicht jedem alles gleich gefallen
und was bringt es und was macht, worauf man gar keinen Bock hat, das stimmt wohl, ja, ich
weiß nicht, was das sein soll, das bestimmt irgendein Not-Safe-For-Work, das Studium der
Wolken, aha, alles klar, deswegen für die Cloud, BWL, hör mal auf, wie gesagt, ich
habe mal eine Ausbildung angefangen im BWL-Bereich, bin froh, dass ich das nicht gemacht habe,
froh, dass ich mich da ganz schnell wieder vom Acker gemacht habe, alles schon ewig
her, 20 Jahre her, Visual Studio ist ganz ok, aber ganz ehrlich, Rider finde ich besser,
kann ich auch nicht verstehen, gibt es aber genug Leute, oh ja, ich habe den installiert,
tatsächlich, ich habe mein Surface Book installiert, letzte Woche, ähm, Donnerstag, also, ich
habe Archlinux drauf gemacht, by the way, sollte ich vielleicht mal erwähnen, dass
ich Archlinux installiert habe, allerdings nicht wie der richtig krasse Hackerman, sondern
ich habe es mit dem Arch-Installer gemacht, läuft, ja, ich habe aber keine Sonderfunktion
getestet, also, es funktioniert die Tastatur, es funktioniert der Bildschirm in voller Auflösung,
ca. 1400, noch was, mal sonst was, das Touchpad funktioniert, mehr habe ich nicht ausprobiert,
aber es geht, oh, WinGet hier, der immer Sachen richtig deinstallieren kann, easy,
machst du noch viel Ruby, hast du mich raten, ihr habt noch irgendeine Legacy Rails Anwendung,
ja, Fleet verstehe ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt, mal gucken, mal gucken, was dabei
rauskommt, richtig, du hast recht, ich verdiene mit dem Streams Geld, also doch, C-Sharp Bro,
ja, tatsächlich, nutzt du eigentlich eine VM und da hast du Dualboot, ich habe eine VM,
guck, das ist eine VM hier, zack, VM, Windows, VM, Windows, also nvim, also ganz ehrlich,
.NET kann ich mir nicht in so einem Command Line Text Editor vorstellen, ich meine jetzt
mit Language Server und sowas mag das alles gehen, aber Rider ist einfach beste, ja wahrscheinlich
aber auch wegen den passenden Plugins dann, hast du eine Meinung zu MOBA Xterm, ja, ich
habe das tatsächlich auf der Arbeit längere Zeit verwendet bzw. verwenden müssen, dann
immer, wenn ich doch mal irgendwo was unter Windows machen musste, das ist ganz okay,
wobei ich mittlerweile eindeutig WSL und das neue Windows Terminal bevorzugen würde
versus MOBA Xterm, der riesen Vorteil von MOBA Xterm ist halt, da kommt auch ein X-Server
mit, also wenn du bei irgendwelche grafischen Anwendungen über X rüberholen musst, dann
ist das besser, dann geht das einfach, aber ansonsten würde ich eher WSL und das Windows
Terminal heute total bevorzugen. Ja, Visual Studio Code konnte vor ein paar Jahren auch
nicht viel und flieht jetzt auch nicht, die Sache ist halt die, Visual Studio Code ist
ja auch nur zu dem geworden, was es ist, weil es viele Plugins gibt und naja, weil es JavaScript
gibt, deswegen gibt es viele Plugins und ich weiß halt nicht, ob viele Leute jetzt Bock
haben, Java Plugins, die es übrigens noch gar nicht gibt, für Fleet zu bauen als Ersatz
für Visual Studio Code, wenn es doch Visual Studio Code gibt und die Sachen eigentlich
schon ziemlich gut macht, der weiß nicht, ob Fleet so der Renner wird, ich sehe es aktuell
noch nicht. Fertig, nee. Wie viel Plan hast du von Flutter? Sekunde, wir haben die beste
Flutter Anwendung aller Zeiten erstellt, also ich bin absoluter Flutter Expert. Guck mal
Leute, die beste Flutter Anwendung überhaupt. Kannst du den Sound auch abspielen, wenn du
aufs Bild drückst? Wenn es einen On-Click, wenn es einen On-Click hat. Oh guck mal, die
gibt den Rahmen nicht wieder. Ja, Massive. Massive Anwendung gebaut in Flutter hier.
Wieso ist das weniger, wollen wir das letzte Mal? So, nee, ich habe keine große Ahnung
von Flutter. Hast du schon mal dein Terminal Setup Workflow vorgestellt? Wir haben ein paar
Streams gemacht, wo ich ein bisschen Linux Zeug eingerichtet habe, ja. Will mich umorientieren,
was mit Landwirtschaft machen, kein Bock auf IT. Hattest du nicht letztens noch eine Nachricht
geschrieben und dass du mir das schmackhaft machen wolltest, dort wo du arbeitest, dass
das so geil ist? Ich meine mich erinnern zu können. Oder ist es dir jetzt einfach so
nicht mehr danach? Welchen Tiling-Venom-Manager verwendest du? I3. Verwende ich. I3 Gaps, aber
ich kann es dir auch auf der Arbeit nebenbei verfolgen, was aktuell ist passiert. Und ganz
ehrlich, ja, verstehe ich, ist bestimmt auch in dem Umfang, wie ich das mache, für viele
nicht möglich. Erstens, weil ich Teilzeit arbeite und zweitens, weil ich absolutes Keller-Kind
bin. Also wie gesagt, wenn ich nicht streame, YouTube mache, bastel ich irgendwelchen Technik-Grammen
von Heim-Automatisierung bis irgendwelche Micro-Controller-Grammen bis irgendwelche
Software-Geschichten, für die ich mich interessiere. Aktuell, was weiß ich, was wir schon alles
gemacht haben im Stream von Web-Assembly bis irgendwelche Tür-Gegensprech-Anlagen und
sonst was. Ja, wenn man komplette Snow-Life wie ich mache, dann ist das kein Thema. Und
wenn man dann noch nur Teilzeit arbeitet, ja. Aber ich kann es verstehen, wenn du 40 Stunden
die Woche arbeitest, vielleicht noch irgendwie Familie am Start hast, die auch was von dir
haben will, plus vielleicht noch andere Hobbys hast. Also Leute, ehrlich gesagt, mein Tag
sieht folgendermaßen aus. Nehmen wir mal einen Home-Office-Tag, ja. Nehmen wir mal
einen Home-Office-Tag. Ich stehe auf, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 7.15 Uhr oder so, setze mich
an den Rechner und schreibe in den Chat, Leute, Home-Office geht los. So. Dann arbeite ich
was bis 15.30 Uhr oder so. 15, 15.30 Uhr. Manchmal 16 Uhr. 12, 13 Uhr gehe ich mal was
futtern. So, dann arbeite ich so bis 15.30 Uhr. Dann gehe ich mich 2 Stunden bewegen.
Und dann sitze ich den restlichen Tag vor dem Rechner. Und dann gehe ich schlafen. Oder
wieder von vorne. Der Tag hat zu wenig Stunden, ja, das stimmt. Also ich sitze quasi 90% des
Tages in der Gugud. Das Benefiz von 24 Stunden nimmst du nicht. Aber ich sitze quasi nur
vom Rechner, sofern ich mich nicht draußen bewegen gehe. Ich sitze vom Rechner oder
ich mache meine 2 Stunden Bewegung draußen. Die jeder machen sollte, weil ansonsten kriegt
man wirklich über Kürze oder Langprobleme. Also Rechner sitzen, 2 Stunden bewegen, Rechner
sitzen, schlafen, Rechner sitzen, bewegen, Rechner sitzen, schlafen. So ist es ungefähr
aus. Was heißt 2 Stunden spazieren? Meistens gehe ich, ich habe es euch schon mal gezeigt,
in welchen Ecken ich beispielsweise laufe, wie das so vom Profil aussieht. Also ich gehe
ganz gern bei uns hier im Umland ein bisschen wandern. Also nicht, dass ich da joggen würde
oder so. Aber ich gehe da halt in, ist nicht gemächlich. Ich gehe da halt recht zügig
so ein bisschen die Berge hoch und runter. Also zum Beispiel, ich zeige euch jetzt die
gleiche Strecke, die ich euch letztens gezeigt habe, weil ich nicht mal mehr Strecken zeigen
will. Also zum Beispiel, wo ich ganz gerne laufe, ist bei uns hier so Richtung Spessart.
Klein Hemsbach zum Beispiel. Hört ihr schon, so übelst beschissen Kleiderl ist es auch.
Kommt mal, hier laufe ich zum Beispiel ganz gerne. Wie macht man hier Layers? So, Moment,
ich will Google Earth. Moment, Google Earth will ich haben. Und das ganze, da kannst du
mich abfangen, wenn du den passenden Tag erwischst, ja. Wanderweg League, also. Google Earth,
please. Please. Da habe ich euch letztes Mal doch schon gezeigt, guckt mal. Sieht
sehr hübsch aus da, seht ihr hier oben ja auch schon. So, guckt, da laufe ich zum Beispiel
ganz gerne. So, das ist so eine Runde, die finde ich nice. Das ist übrigens falsch,
wo ich hier gucke. Ja, also das laufe ich zum Beispiel ganz gerne hier. Hier unten
kann man, hier unten ist übrigens auch ein Bahnhof, hier unten. Aber hier kann man gut
parken unten. So, und jetzt machen wir mal Achtung. So, und dann kann man hier wunderbar
durch die Berge laufen. Das sind so richtig kleine Furzdörfchen. Geht man dann hier lang,
berghoch, weiter, berghoch, dann irgendwann hier rüber. Ups, Onkel S. Ja, und dann hier
hoch, dann hier hoch, dann hier durch und auf der anderen Seite wieder runter. Ja, also
das ist so eine, das ist ungefähr so eine Runde, die ich, die ich gerne, gerne laufe.
Naja, ob das jetzt Hügel oder Berg nennt, ist doch egal. Also das ist, also der höchste
Berg hier ist glaube ich 480 Meter oder so. Da brauchst du ungefähr zwei Stunden für
die Runde. Ja, für die Schweizer ist das natürlich kein Berg. Also da brauchst du
ungefähr zwei Stunden, wenn du hier so eine Runde läufst. Und es ist halt nice, das ist
halt so richtig ruhige Gegend. Guckt, hier unten ist ein bisschen was, dann läufst du
hier, hier ist keine Sau Leute, hier ist einfach keine Sau. Niemand ist hier, niemand. Niemand.
Dann läufst du hier weiter und dann wird das, und dann kommst du dann zu so ganz kleinen,
so ganz kleinen Dörfchen zum Beispiel, sowas wie hier. Das hat nur eine Straße, ja. Aber
das da halt, ihr seht es vielleicht ein bisschen von oben. Guck mal, hier wird beispielsweise
auch gebaut gerade. Ohne Scheiß, ich glaube vor 15 Jahren waren da nur halb so viele Häuser.
Also ohne Mist, alle Häuser mit diesem hellen Dach sind neu. Also die Hälfte des Dorfes
ist in den letzten 10 Jahren dazugekommen oder in den letzten 5 Jahren dazugekommen. Und
ich könnte wetten, ganz viele dieser Leute, die dahin gezogen sind, sind Leute, die früher
irgendwie in Frankfurt gearbeitet haben und jetzt Homeoffice machen können. Das hat halt
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 40 Einwohner oder so, da ist nichts. Das ist quasi Homeoffice-Siedlung.
Aber man sieht hier ein bisschen, sag mal so, wenn man das läuft, ganz im Ernst, man muss
hier kein Bergsteiger sein für okay. Aber ein bisschen geht es hier schon hoch und runter,
ja. Ja, also das zum Beispiel, sowas, das laufe ich so ungefähr 2 Stunden die Runde,
relativ zügig. Also ich muss mich in der Wande-App schon auf athletisch stellen, das ist ungefähr
mit der Zeitangabe hinkommt, was auch immer das sagen soll. Also ich schleiche da nicht
total. So, dann habe ich mich 2 Stunden bewegt am Tag, dann geht es mir besser und dann sitze
ich wieder vorm Rechner. Easy und dann gehe ich pennen irgendwann. Wo ist der Unterschied
von Arch-Installer zu Manjaro? Naja, dass Manjaro eine andere Distro ist. Und Arch-Installer
ist halt ein richtig echtes Arch-Lilungs-By-The-Way und Manjaro nicht. Wiesbaden ist auch super,
das ist ein bisschen weiter weg. Ich hänge 6 Minuten hinterher, ja, ich sehe es schon.
Was hältst du von der Zukunft mit C-Sharp und Java? Java habe ich keine Ahnung, C-Sharp
hat eine super Zukunft. Gibt es laufend neue Updates, neue Sachen, super aktives Ökosystem,
vielleicht nicht so krass wie Javascript, aber welche Sprache hat schon so aktives
Ökosystem wie Javascript. Aber super, kannst du die nächsten Jahre eigentlich nichts mit
falsch machen. Was ist deine Meinung zu Anyrun? Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist. Interactive
Online Mailware Sandbox. Nie verwendet. Wie hast du das neue YouTube Update-Spiel einfach
draufgegangen und dann war es da? Stuhl, ist das mein Stuhl? Ja, den habe ich. Würde
ich übrigens im Leben nicht für den Preis kaufen, Leute, sage ich euch gleich. Das muss
günstiger sein. Wenn es günstiger ist, dann könnt ihr es euch kaufen. Ich habe glaube
ich 1200 Euro oder so damals bezahlt, was immer noch viel viel zu teuer ist für einen
Stuhl. Aber im Ernst, wenn ihr den ganzen Tag drauf sitzt, spart kein Geld. Spart kein
Geld beim Klo und spart kein Geld beim Stuhl und spart kein Geld beim höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch und sowas. Das ist FFZ als Addon, ja. Ikea Markus geht auch, ja. Ich glaube
der Friseur hatte nur Ikea Markus damals. Mehrfach. Aber ich kann euch halt einen guten Stuhl wirklich
nur ans Herz legen. Es muss ja kein super super teurer Luxus-Premium-24-7-Stuhl was auch
immer sein. Aber ein ordentlicher Stuhl macht ja keinen Sinn zu sparen an der Stelle, wenn
man da so viel davor sitzt. Ja kann ich verstehen. Die Sache ist die, dass ich mit keine neuen
Leute kennenlernen. Der Rest verstehe ich ja. Hast du eine Brille? Nein. Hab ich nicht.
Ich hab auch keine Brille und ich brauch wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit auch keine Brille. Ich hab
150% Sehstärke gehabt vor ein paar Jahren. Wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt bei 100 oder
so. Also ich hab vor 6 Jahren oder so mal einen Sehtest gemacht und da hatte ich immer
noch 150% Sehstärke. Und wer sich jetzt fragt, wie kann man 150% haben, das funktioniert
folgendermaßen. Normaler Test auf normaler Entfernung ist 100% und wenn man das dann
quasi noch weiter sieht als normale Entfernung dann 150%. Das heißt selbst wenn ich jetzt
schlechter sehe, habe ich wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch genug. Nein, ich hab keine Brille und
brauche in nächster Zeit auch keine Brille. Hoffe ich zumindest. Kein Bock auf Boomer-Zeugs
wie Kinderzeugen? Nein. In der Haus muss ich nicht bauen. Haus hab ich eines geerbt vom
Opa. Kinderzeugen, also es gibt wirklich eine Sache auf die ich wirklich, es gibt nicht
viel worauf ich weniger Bock habe als Kinder zu zeugen. Weniger auf das eigentliche Zeugen
als auf das Kinderbekommen habe ich keinen Bock. Das Kinderzeug ist ja dabei noch am
besten, aber das brauch ich nicht. Wanderweg League, ja. Badminton Kurs, hei hei hei. Ist
dir das nicht langweilig was? 2 Stunden rumlaufen zu gehen? Nö. Wenn du den ganzen Tag vorm
Rechner sitzt ist es tatsächlich mal ganz entspannend 2 Stunden durch die Natur zu laufen
und falls du meinst wir vom Rechner sitzen? Ne, sonst würde ich es ja nicht machen. Richtig.
Ja. Keine Ahnung. Wär auch eine Möglichkeit. Hörst du Musik dabei oder genießt du Naturgeräusche?
Also ist unterschiedlich. Manchmal hör ich ein bisschen YouTube oder Livestream oder
irgendwelche Konferenztalks oder irgendwas was mich interessiert, aber meistens hab ich
tatsächlich nichts auf dem Ohr und laufe einfach nur so rum. Ja, easy mach mal. Wie viele Kilometer
bist du unterwegs? Was wird denn das sein? Max schaut Poki beim Wandern, jetzt verraten
ich alles. Poki W. Check im Chat. Was wird denn das sein so? Was ist denn die Runde so
wahrscheinlich so 10, 11 Kilometer oder so? Ich kann in der Wander App gucken. Das geht
von 8, ich sag mal so, das geht von 8 bis bis 13 Kilometer oder so in dem Dreh denke
ich. Je nachdem wie groß die Runde ist und wie schnell ich laufe. Also 8 Kilometer schaffe
ich relativ easy in, ich denk mal so eineinhalb Stunde 15, eineinhalb Stunden oder so. Ah,
Stunde 15, eineinhalb Stunden, irgendwie so in dem Dreh. Je nachdem, wenn es natürlich
8 Kilometer mit Feedback hoch ist, dann ist es natürlich langsamer und für so 10 Kilometer
wird es hier wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden brauchen. Jeden Tag, ja. Jeden Tag, außer sonntags.
Sonntags meistens gar nicht oder weniger, aber sonst jeden Tag. One Walking mit Stöckchen,
ich laufe immer mit Stöckchen. Ich hab immer Stöckchen dabei. Das ist für den Rücken
viel entspannter mit Stöcken zu laufen als einfach nur so. Boomer, ja klar. Ich hab immer
so Nordic Walking Stöcke dabei. G-Stock mit Klinge, ist keine Klinge drin, aber wenn
man die Gummifüße abmacht, ist es auch relativ spitz. So richtig, nein, nein, nein, richtige
Walking Stöcke sind das. Leute, wir haben heute vor 15 Minuten was Sinnvolles gemacht,
ja? Der Rest war sinnloses Gelaber, aber dafür seid ihr ja da, oder? Manjaro Maintainer verkacken
das mit den Zertifikaten. Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum die sich da so schwer
machen. So, ich glaub gleich hab ich den Chat aufgeholt. Jetzt werden die Secrets ausgeplaudert
wieder. Ne, das mach ich nicht. Vielleicht will ich ja doch mal irgendwann Nachwuchs
haben. Ich hab's aktuell nicht vor und wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit auch nicht, aber vielleicht
irgendwann mal. Kann ja sein. Was? Riso sucht Entwickler, ja, da kann er mal suchen. Ne,
wie gesagt, ich laufe meistens ohne irgendwas auf dem Ohr. Wie, was ist mit euch los? Keiner,
keiner Pokis ab. Zehn Kilometer, zwei Stunden sind schon sehr flott. Ja, wie gesagt, ich
muss mich in der Wander App auf Athletisch stellen, dass es mit der Zeit halbwegs hinkommt.
Doch, aber das kommt gut hin. Zehn Kilometer, zwei Stunden. Was läuft man dann? Fünf Stunden
Kilometer, oder? Quickmuffs. Ich mein, wie gesagt, das geht aber auch nur, also das geht
berghoch nicht. Das geht nur geradeaus. Also relativ flach. Wenn es berghoch geht, da
brauchst du die zwei Stunden auch für weniger. Stimmt ist ja auch wieder, dann ist jetzt
schon wieder viel früher dunkler. Äh, ja, noch mal, ist viel früher dunkler. Das find
ich immer blöd, weil, also mir ist lieber, ich laufe halt, wenn ein bisschen Sonne ist,
was du halt teilweise jetzt vergessen kannst, wenn es 15.30 Uhr dann schon anfängt, dunkel
zu werden. Das wird die Frage irgendwie geil. Je Stock mit Klinge. Ne, aber, zwar ohne Mist,
ich bin vor ein paar Tagen wieder rumgelaufen, da gab es wieder so ein Dude mit drei Hunden,
der die wieder nicht richtig an der Leine hatte, beziehungsweise die nehmen wollte, wenn man
vorbeiläuft. Also, ich glaube nicht, dass man einen G-Stock mit Klinge für braucht,
das braucht man eher in Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof, aber ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich nicht
doch so irgendwie einen Spray oder so mir einen Gürtel heften soll, wenn ich da durch
die Pampa laufe. Weil ganz im Ernst, es gibt schon teilweise richtige, richtige Drecksäcke
als Hundebesitzer, die das dann auch noch lustig finden. Wunder Stream. Leute, irgendwann
mache ich Wunder-Livestream. Wunder-Livestream, Leute. Kommt ein Video, ja, ja, ja. Gibt's,
auf jeden Fall gibt's das. Ich hatte heute keine Zeit, groß zu spielen, aber ich hab
schon mal 50 MB runtergeladen und installiert. Morgen werde ich mir das angucken und vielleicht
schon morgen was aufnehmen, aber ich glaube, morgen hochladen wird schwierig, wenn ich
mir so recht überlege. Ja, genau, benutze ich. Ja, die ist wirklich nicht schlecht. Eine
der wenigsten Apps, wo ich wirklich Pay2Win gemacht hab und mir ein paar Sachen gekauft
hab drin. Aber ich hab schon so viele Strecken damit gelaufen und gefunden, also ich finde
die Wunder-App echt gut. Gibt ja tausende Wunder-Apps, ja. Ich dachte, irgendwie der
Internet-Explorer kriegt jetzt irgendwelche Logos, aber nee. Das hast du dir jetzt ausgedacht,
aber ich kann es mir bei manchen Leuten tatsächlich vorstellen. War nice. Poggers. Und Tschüss.
Poggers. Wie ist das eigentlich so dumm an? Aber warum nicht? Twitch-Chat-Emotes, die
müssen einfach überall allgemein akzeptiert werden. Leute, wisst ihr, wieviel einfacher
Kommunikation wäre, wenn man in echt auch mit Twitch-Emotes kommunizieren könnte? Es
ist so schwierig, immer rüberzubringen, rein mit Betonung, wie man jetzt was meint. Wenn
man dann beispielsweise danach sagen könnte, Cackle oder Easy oder Lulvee oder so, das
wird vieles vereinfachen. Deswegen gibt es Gesichtsausdrücke. Nee, Emotes sind viel
besser. Da weißt du genau, was gemeint ist, weil du weißt, was die Emotes bedeuten. Gesichtsausdrücke
musst du dir überlegen. Wie meint er das jetzt? So sieht es aus. Wie gesagt, ich stand
auch letztens beim Subway oder was um Subway-Verschnittladen und habe Cackle gesagt. Haben sie auch alle
nicht verstanden. Haben sie gesagt, was? Ja, dann würdest du sagen, das hast du aber ganz
toll gemacht, Cup. Oder Kappa, wenn man Oldschool ist. Wie war die allererste Twitch-Copypasta?
Das war ganz, ganz alt, Twitch-Anfänge. Das war die Zeiten, wo Leute noch FrankerZ und
sowas verwendet haben. Da will ich nicht hin, ich will die App verwenden. FrankerZ, FrankerZ,
FrankerZ, FrankerZ. Gesichterpasen ist wirklich weird, Champ. Das kann alles bedeuten. Manche
Leute haben auch keine Emotionen, wenn sie was sagen. Und da fragst du dich immer so
im Gesicht und da fragst du dich, wie meint er das jetzt? Ja, Twitch-Emojis sind viel,
viel praktischer als Emojis. Emojis sind schon okay, so als Baseline, weil es irgendwie jeder
kennt und jeder hat. Aber Twitch-Emojis ist einfach das, wo man sich wirklich am besten
mit verständigen kann. Ja, jeder hat ein Gesicht, aber wie gesagt, manche Leute bewegen auch
ihr Gesicht gar nicht, du weißt nicht, wie sie was meinen und da musst du Gesichtsausdrücke
interpretieren. Twitch-Emojis wären viel besser. Man könnte ja Twitch-Emojis noch unterstützend.
Ja, das stelle ich euch mal vor, jemand bringt einen Witz, lacht und dann sagt er noch CackW
hinten dran. Dann weißt du sofort, dass es ein Witz sein sollte, auch wenn du nicht lustig
fandest. Und wenn es nur so ein kleiner Joke war, sagt er dann halt LUL. Unicode ist ganz
toll, vor allem, weil es irgendwie 20 verschiedene Leerzeichen gibt und sowas, Widespaces. Weird
Jemp, ja, Weird Jemp würde ich auch gerne zu manchen Aussagen auf der Arbeit öfters
mal sagen. Und es wäre halt gut, wenn der andere das direkt verstehen würde. Ja, da
kommt dann einer an und sagt, hier, das ist in PHP programmiert, er sagt Weird Jemp. Und
dann würde er sofort verstehen, was ich meine. Oder zum Beispiel, letztens wurde mir erzählt,
dass in der anderen Gruppe haben sie jetzt ihre Einstellungstests erneuert. Unter anderem
ein Einstellungstest ist, die Leute sollen irgendeinen PowerShell-Skript erklären. Und
da hätte ich auch gerne ihnen den Weird Jemp gegeben dafür. Ich hab auch gesagt, wie PowerShell,
Weird Jemp. Ja, komplett Weird Jemp. Was willst du mit PowerShell? PowerShell ist ja an sich
nicht verkehrt. Ganz im Ernst, PowerShell ist schon in Ordnung. PowerShell ist halt
eine miese interaktive Shell, aber für reine Automatisierung ist PowerShell schon in Ordnung.
Leute, jetzt mit unserer Skillliste wird nichts mehr heute. Ich glaube, es ist schon 22, ja,
es ist 22 Uhr. 15 sogar. Eigentlich ist jetzt Boomer muss ins Bett angesagt, wisst ihr das?
Aber es ist Samstag. Da ist das nicht so akut. Vielleicht bleibe ich nochmal noch eine halbe
Stunde oder so da. Seien es gibt irgendwas. Die alte Skillliste ist aber Weird Jemp. Kann
man so nicht verwenden. Hat jemand vielleicht eine Idee, was man als Projekt... Ah, das
ist eine Frage, die kommt immer hier im Stream. Total oft. Wenn du nicht weißt, wie du anfangen
sollst, ist die große Frage, was hat dich zum Programmieren gebracht? Musst du es für
die Schule lernen? Musst du es für das Studium lernen? Wie kommst du darauf? Ich kann dir
an der Stelle eigentlich nur eine Sache empfehlen, wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast und auch nicht
weißt, mit welcher Sprache du anfangen sollt, sonst was, schnapp dir den Browser, schnapp
dir den Texteditor und bastel bisschen mit JavaScript, HTML und CSS rum, weil dann siehst
du auch direkt, was passiert. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich noch weitere super Einstiegssprachen.
Python ist gut, Go. Ich bin nicht der Go-Fan, aber Go ist auch okay als Einstieg. Ich persönlich
mag C Sharp auch. Ruby ist auch gut, wobei Ruby nicht mehr so angesagt ist. Aber was
hat dich denn jetzt dazu gebracht, dass du programmieren lernen willst? C++ ist keine
gute Einstiegssprache. O, B, A, MonkaS. Ja, Physix, warum willst du was programmieren?
Weil du willst oder weil du musst? Jetzt kommen sie alle mit ihren super lustigen Jokes
hier wieder an im Chat. Ja, Java ist tatsächlich, kann man auch machen, wenn man sich quälen
will. Fortran, ja Cobol ist auch nicht schlecht. Du meinst das ernst? C ist die beste Einstiegssprache.
Ja, C ist insofern schön, weil es sehr übersichtlich ist, was eingebaut ist. Aber mit C was zu
machen ist nicht einfach. Es ist auch äußerst minimalistisch. Ne, also C ist auch vom Handling
her, ne. Doch finde ich schon. Man muss kein Assembly bzw. keine Hardware Know-How haben
um was zu programmieren. Ich meine, mit der Zeit, spätestens wenn du mal ein bisschen
an Performance Optimierung denkst, später, weil es nicht so rund läuft, dann muss man
sich eh früher oder später mit so ein bisschen grundlegender Sachen beschäftigen. Aber gerade
am Anfang ist wichtig, dass man so ein bisschen den Ablauf checkt, so was ist ein If, wann
mache ich eine Schleife, wann packe ich was in der extra Funktion, wie benenne ich den
ganzen Kram. Und da muss man sich dann nicht auch noch mit irgendwelchen Hardware Instruktionen
auseinandersetzen. C++ ist Müll. Ja gut, das stimmt, man kann vieles auf andere Sprachen
übertragen. Das kann man aber beispielsweise mit, was weiß ich, selbst wenn es Java ist,
C++ machen im Studium Java auch. Da muss man sich nicht mit C++ rumquälen. Es gibt für
mich eigentlich nur eine logische Erklärung, wenn man C++ nimmt. Man nimmt C++ immer dann,
wenn es keine andere Alternative dazu gibt. Das ist zum Beispiel, wenn man Unreal und
sowas interne Sachen, Unreal programmieren will, ja, kommst nicht dran vorbei. Wenn man
beispielsweise WebAssembly machen will, ja, da gibt es Rust und sonst was, aber C++ ist
auch eine super Lösung dafür. Oder wenn man irgendwelche Microcontroller Sachen machen
will, wo halt die Standard Sachen in C bzw. gerade bei Arduino und C++ sind. Ansonsten
gibt es eigentlich meiner Meinung nach gar keinen großartigen Sinn C++ zu verwenden.
Von C rede ich nicht, sondern von C++. Ja, C++ ist schnell, das ist aber auch das Einzige,
was C++ ist. Carbon wird sich meiner Ansicht nach nicht durchsetzen. Ach ja, wir hatten
das jetzt noch mal gefragt hier oben. Wo habe ich jetzt überhaupt was zu? Hat er was geantwortet?
Physix, ok, hat Physix was geschrieben? Excel-Marcos, Leute, es gibt Sachen,
damit werde ich mich nie freiwillig beschäftigen. Aus Interesse. Ja, ok, weil warum ich gefragt
habe ist, meistens ist es ja so, wenn jemand rein aus Interesse anfängt zu programmieren,
dann hat er irgendwas im Kopf, was er machen will, nicht, es vielleicht noch nicht gibt
oder nicht so wie er das gerne hätte und dann hat er sich gedacht, ah, das könnte ich ja
vielleicht selbst machen. Zumindest ist es bei mir immer so, wenn ich mir irgendwas Neues
angucken will. Ja, ja, dann würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen, also es sei denn du
hast gar keinen Bock auf JavaScript. Würde ich dir tatsächlich JavaScript empfehlen,
du brauchst einen Textedit und einen Browser, kannst anfangen. Falls dir Webseiten gefallen,
ja. Aber gerade JavaScript hat halt viele Vorteile. Also mein erstes war das riesen
Ökosystem mittlerweile, also du kannst mit JavaScript mittlerweile alles machen, auch
auf dem Server, auch auf dem Desktop, sogar grafische Anwendung, wenn du mit dem RAM-Verbrauch
keine Probleme hast. Aber letztendlich bleibt es natürlich im Browser zu Hause, ja, ist
klar. Aber JavaScript hat viele Vorteile. Wie gesagt, großes Ökosystem und vor allem
eine riesen Anzahl an Tutorials und Kursen und auch vieles kostenlos. Ja, five fat Hausmeister
habt ihr. Ja, für Windows Geschichten ist.NET natürlich auch nice, weil da vieles
halt erstmal in.NET zur Verfügung steht, wo vor Microsoft Sachen für andere Sprachen
zur Verfügung stehen. Also wenn ich was für Windows jemals wieder machen müsste, dann
würde ich es auch eindeutig immer sofort in die Schacht machen. Hat jemand Empfehlungen
für Home Server, OS, Ubuntu Server, Proxmox und Windows Server? Was ist dann der hauptsächliche
Einsatzzweck dieses Home Servers? Container Geschichten laufen lassen, VMs laufen lassen,
Game Automatisierung, was ist der hauptsächliche Netzwerk Storage? Alles so ein bisschen testen.
Also wenn du was lernen willst, Ubuntu Server, dann musst du es nämlich selbst machen, was
gar nicht so schwer ist heutzutage. Ja, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Linux Basic und
Linux Administration heutzutage super, super harte Kost ist. Aber du lernst auf jeden Fall
einiges dabei. Spätestens wenn du zum ersten Mal Wim aufgemacht hast und feststellst,
Mist, ich komm nicht mehr raus. Oder wie lockt man sich PSSH ein? Gut, also Ubuntu Server,
wenn du Linux Technik was lernen willst, kann ich dir neben Ubuntu Server, Windows Server
auf gar keinen Fall, egal in welcher Kombination, scheiß drauf. Es sei denn du willst irgendwas
machen, was Windows Only ist, aber dann würde ich mir was anderes suchen. Also Windows Server
kannst du schon mal streichen. Proxmox würde ich auch nur verwenden, wenn du viele VMs hast.
Ja, ich weiß, manche machen da auch Container und viele machen dann auch Docker in LXC Container
und sowas. Aber Proxmox ist tatsächlich was, wenn du viele VMs haben willst oder viele
Container und eigentlich eher ein Management Interface brauchst für viele separate Kisten
und kein Bock auf ESX hast oder so. Also ich denke, die meisten Leute, die Proxmox verwenden,
die wissen wann sie es brauchen und wann nicht. Und wenn man nicht weiß, dass man es braucht,
will man das wahrscheinlich nicht als Standard OS für seine Kiste haben. Unrate ist tatsächlich,
weil sie jemand vorgeschlagen haben, gar nicht so blöd. Ich persönlich hab ja seit einer
Weile jetzt auch, ich fand's ja immer kacke, ich hab's ja auch immer geflamed. Ich hab
jetzt aber auch seit einer Weile eine Unrate Kiste, weil ich weiß, es hat ein paar Sachen,
die mir auf den Keks gehen. Zum Beispiel, dass es Slackware als Basis hat. Und Slackware
ist halt so die cringieste Distribution, die du heutzutage verwenden kannst. Kriegst nichts
drauf, kriegst nichts, wie auch immer. Aber zumindest, du musst ja auch kaum was drauf
machen. Also Unrate finde ich insofern ganz nice, weil's eben ein schickes Frontend hat.
Es hat kein so gutes Frontend für Virtualisierung wie jetzt Proxmox. Aber gerade, wenn du ein
paar Container laufen lassen willst und nur drei Klicks machen möchtest, Gui haben willst
zum konfigurieren, ja, manche sagen dann ja, dann mach ich dann halt noch irgendwie ein
Portainer Addon und mach das damit. Oder manche haben ja daheim einen kompletten Rancher OS
und Kuba, nee, das hast du nicht, brauch mal alles nicht. Das ist alles overkill. Das
ist cool, wenn man's lernen will, aber brauchen tust du das daheim natürlich nicht. Deswegen
finde ich die Kombination von dem UI was Unrate hat plus die Basisfunktion eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so schlecht. Ja, also wenn man sich wirklich wenig drum kümmern will und
es einfach irgendwie funktionieren soll, ist Unrate gar nicht so verkehrt. Ansonsten eindeutig
Ubuntu Server. Also ich würde dir empfehlen, wenn du was lernen willst, nimm einen Ubuntu
Server oder einen Debian, aber Ubuntu ist auch okay. Ich muss sagen, ihr kennt mich,
ihr wisst, dass ich immer für alle Sachen Ubuntu Server verwende. Auch die Hetzner Streams,
die man gemacht hat, immer Ubuntu Server, aber in letzter Zeit muss ich sagen, irgendwie
gab es jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal wieder ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben an
Ubuntu Server. Ich setze vermehrt in letzter Zeit tatsächlich Debian wieder ein und nicht
nur auf dem Raspberry Pi. Also aktuell würde ich wahrscheinlich die default Installation
sogar eher in Debian machen als mit Ubuntu. Die haben wenigstens ordentliche Netzwerk-Config
und nicht so komisches Jammel-Gedöns. Homeserver gleich Stromverbrauch? Wieso? Nass ist doch
auch nichts anderes. Was meinst du, was im Nass drinnen steckt? Bei den meisten Nassgeräten
steckt der 0815x86 CPU drin. Also was kannst du dir auch so kaufen? Du wirst es vielleicht
nicht so schön kompakt und mit diesen Sachen in so ein Gehäuse mit Wechselrahmen und so
kriegen wie bei deinem Nass, aber du bist halt deutlich flexibler damit. Unter der Haube
ist so ein Synology Nass auch nur ein Low-Power Intel-Onboard-Teil und die bisschen teureren
halt was anderes. Macht keinen Unterschied. Low-Power Intel x86-Kiste ist im Eidl genauso
Low-Power wie dein Nass. Ich muss sagen, ich bin kein großer Portainer-Fan. Ich verstehe
den Charme, warum das viele benutzen. Ich mag's nicht. Ist aber Geschmackssache. Wim
ist Hyper-Pog. Ja, Wim ist Beste. Na, da hast du das Kribbste ja schon hinter dir. Ja,
das macht erstmal überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Das macht erst in advancederer Benutzung Unterschiede.
Aber für so... Ich möchte den Editor aufmachen zum editieren und mach vielleicht ein paar
Basic-Settings, macht es keinen Unterschied. Gibt es eigentlich schon einen einfachen
Docker-Container, mit dem man sofort zur Last rumpelt? Das wär's ja. Ich wähl für
einen Docker-Container, den du startest und dann schwingen sich ein paar Inder oder so
aufs Fahrrad und strampeln. Da bist du nämlich auch wetterunabhängig. Ja Leute, ich mach
zu wenig Sellout für Prime. Ich seh's schon, ich muss mehr Sellout machen. Melon Man hat
Subscribed vorhin noch. Dankeschön, hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Und jetzt... 3D Man, 3D,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich muss echt öfter Sellout machen. Das klappt immer. Bei den
anderen Streamern, wo ich ab und zu mal gucke, die haben es auch mittlerweile schon voll
drauf, so die krassen Prime-Sub-Überleitungen zu machen und dann gibt's immer direkt mit
reingesubbt. Aber ich mach das ja nicht unbedingt, weil ich maximale Subs abgreifen will. Insofern.
Ja. Debian läuft einfach. Fire and Forgetters Server. Ja gut, Ubuntu läuft ja prinzipiell
auch. Aber mir geht bei Ubuntu einiges auf den Keks. Also im Desktop zum Beispiel diese
ganze Snap-Geschichte. Auf dem Server teilweise auch Snap, was da überhaupt nichts zu suchen
hat meiner Ansicht nach. Zumindest nicht Default. Jaml Netzwerk-Config finde ich auch eklig.
Und mir fällt grad nicht mehr ein. Aber ich hatte, muss ich mal überlegen. Aber wie gesagt,
mir fällt grad nicht mehr ein. Ich hatte die letzten paar Monate über mal so zwei, drei
kleine Dinge, wo ich mir gedacht hab, ah irgendwie ist Ubuntu doch nervig in manchen. Obwohl
ich jahrelang Ubuntu auf den, auf Servern verwendet hab. Und jetzt hab ich in letzter
Zeit häufiger Debian am Start. So, also jetzt sind wir aber langsam, jetzt ist aber wirklich
schon spät, oder? Ja, so siehts aus. So siehts aus. Letzter Dreck. Snap ist total Müll.
Was brauchst du denn für einen Package Manager auf Linux? Naja, den, der bei der Distribution
dabei ist. Ja, Abt unter Debian und Ubuntu. Obwohl ja unter Debian und Ubuntu theoretisch,
da kannst du ja Abt, Abt Get, Abt Tweet oder wie das Ding mal zwischenzeitlich hieß. Ähm,
unter Red Hat basierten hast du DNF, aber auch immer noch Jam. Vielleicht ist Jam ja
mittlerweile Link auf DNF. Genthu für die Hardcore Leute. Ja. Nala, kenn ich nicht.
Metapackage Manager. Genau, also ich verwende Pacman beziehungsweise Yay heißt das ja,
Yay. Na, Genthu auf dem Server ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu hart. Da brauch ich was,
wo die Standardsachen dabei sind, was supportet ist und einfach funktioniert. Das ist jetzt
Genthu jetzt unbedingt für den Server nicht gerade das Beste. Zip, oh Gott, Suze, mann,
hör mal auf. Benutzst du ernsthaft Suze? Man, jeder soll benutzen, was er will, ja.
Hab ich nix dagegen, aber ich, eh, Suze ist wirklich so ein Ding. Ich kann Suze nicht
leihen. Suze ist glaube ich so wirklich das mein am least favorite OS, also Linux Distro,
die ich am wenigsten mag. Oje, mein Beilein, Suze mag ich gar nicht. Also wir hatten mal
eine Suze Kiste auf der Arbeit, das war für die Software damals, weiß ich noch, die Software
für die Telefonanlage, aber ich glaube die gibt es mittlerweile nicht mehr. Ja, das ist
ja im Prinzip Ubuntu mit einem extra Hintergrund. Diese ganzen Mini-Distros, die braucht kein
Mensch. Weiß ich eh nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist. Die ändern dann drei Hintergrundbilder
hier, bam, neue Distributionen. Also wenn ich mein Ubuntu besonders cute haben will,
dann nehme ich eindeutig Mo Ubuntu, Leute. Komm, volle, volle Weebladung jetzt erstmal.
Warum brauchen wir das so lange? Gramm voll, Kekkel. Achtung, Weep, Alarm. So, also wenn
mein Betriebssystem cute sein soll, dann eindeutig so. Excellent. Ok, genug für heute cute Ladung,
wieder wegmachen. Auf dem Surface Laptop, oh ne. Ist Manjaro nicht vergleichbar mit was
denn? Mit Genthu? Naja, bei Genthu stehen die Leute ja drauf, sich alles selbst zu kompilieren,
das musst du unter Manjaro eigentlich zum größten Teil nicht machen. Klar, wenn du
irgendwelche User Repos installierst, da ist oftmals Buildscripts dabei. Oh, das ist halt
irgendwas, was Binary runterlädt. Die Rede war von den Subdistros? Achso, ja gut, ja in
gewisser Weise schon, wobei man bei Manjaro tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr ist. Ich
meine, die haben eigene Package-Repos, auch verschiedene Flavors mit vorkonfigurierten
Desktops und so. Das hat schon irgendwie seinen Sinn. Aber so Distributionen, die einfach
nur das Hintergrundbild ändern oder irgendwie drei neue Artiges ins Lounge-Menü machen
und dann sagen hier, geil, neue Distro. Weiß nicht, das braucht kein Mensch. Ne, habe ich
nicht. Chrome OS habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Achja, und Manjaro hat es nicht so mit Zertifikaten,
stimmt. Das stimmt, ja, da hast du recht. Deswegen jetzt nur noch Arch, nur noch echtes
Arch, by the way. Die Manjaro VM fliegt weg, sobald wir die andere mal endlich fertig eingerichtet
haben. Ich wollte mir eh ein paar neue Sachen angucken. Ja, Gnome Terminal ist ja deprecated,
also das, was ich als Terminal verwende, wird ja irgendwie immer weiterentwickelt oder sowas,
haben die ja geschrieben. Könnte man sich ja eine der neuen, coolen GPU beschleunigten
Terminals mal angucken, mal schauen, ob ich mich da mit einem anfreunden kann. Coole Leute
haben ja heute OpenGL-based Terminals, weil's geht. Ich find's jetzt nicht, weil ich hab's
das letzte Mal, als ich euch zeigen wollte, auch nicht gefunden. Und dann kam jemand aus
dem Chat und hat den Link dazu gepostet. Gnome Terminal ist jetzt deprecated und wird ersetzt
beziehungsweise wird sich mit der Weiterentwicklung glaube ich auf Gnome Konsole konzentriert
oder wie hieß das Ding? Wenn du kündigst, musst du das Surface nicht wieder... Ja, jaja,
ich benutze es ja auch nur für die Arbeit. Das Surface Hub, das stelle ich auf die Arbeit
und lass es da für immer stehen. Das einzige, wofür ich das verwende, ist, wenn ich auf
der Arbeit bin, zum Arbeiten damit. Brauche ich auch ordentliche Linux-Distro drauf, dass
ich arbeiten kann gescheit und ab und zu mal zum Remote drauf verbinden, wobei ich das
meiste eigentlich gar nicht mehr brauche, zum Remote verbinden. Lieber Kitty oder Vesturm,
ist Kitty nicht der Entwickler, der T-Max hasst wie die Pest? Der übelst rumflamet über
T-Max immer. Ich glaube schon. Der ist geil. Vesturm, Vesturm. Das benutze ich aber nur
wenn es Blazingly Fast Written in Rust ist. Vesturm. Lol. Was auch sonst, Alter. Natürlich,
Written in Rust Blazingly Fast, ganz klar. What the fuck, Alter. Was ein riesen Ding,
Mann. Rust ist so umständlich in vielen... Ah ne, ok, das Hälfte besteht aus Tests.
Ja, sowas gibt es bei mir nicht. Ok, Vesturm. Vesturm. Ok, das probieren wir das nächste
Mal, ich schreibe hier mal auf. Was war das? Das probieren wir mal aus. Vesturm. Und was
ich auch unbedingt mal ausprobieren will, ist Starship. Auch Blazingly Fast Written in Rust.
Äh. Ja, Starship. Es ist auch Blazingly Fast Written in Rust. Wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Selbe Config? Du meinst die Fall Config oder muss man da viel customisern? Ja, finde ich
auch ziemlich cringe, wer Tests braucht. Also Test-Kommentare ist komplett overrated. Wenn
man fehlerfrei programmiert, braucht man das nicht und dann braucht man auch keine Dokumentation.
Das ist eigentlich... Guck mal, was man da für Ressourcen sparen kann. Just, Just macht
keine Fehler. Easy. Wer testet, denkt, dass es kaputt geht. So siehts aus. Möglich, aber
wahrscheinlich nicht groß benutzt. Was haben eigentlich alle Leute aktuell mit Rust? Tja,
die Rust-Taskforce hat zugeschlagen. Rust ist halt so ein bisschen so die... Hype-Sprache
ist das falsche Wort, aber Rust hat viele sehr lautstarke Anhänger, die allen, die
nicht ihre Sachen in Rust programmieren, permanent erzählen müssen, dass Rust die beste Programmiersprache
ist. Vor ein paar Jahren war das noch Go, da war alles written in Go. Heute ist die coolen
Sachen werden written in Rust. Ich persönlich finde es besser, wenn interessante Projekte
in Rust geritten werden als in Go, weil... Das hat jetzt ganz selbstlose Gründe natürlich
wieder. Weil Interop mit Rust viel, viel, viel einfacher ist von anderen Sprachen als
mit Go. Ja, das ist auch so ein geiles Ding. Dann erklären wir mal, was eine Systemprogrammiersprache
eigentlich genau sein soll. Ich weiß, damit schmeißen die Rust-Leute immer wahnsinnig
um sich, aber wenn du die meisten Sachen anguckst, die in Rust programmiert sind, ich
weiß nicht, mit Systemen hat das wenig zu tun. Ja, genau, genau, zum Beispiel. Einfach,
dass du Rust-Sachen einfacher aufrufen kannst aus anderen Programmiersprachen mit irgendeinem
C-Interface. Diese C-Interface, wie nennt man das? So Call Convention von C hat sich
halt durchgesetzt als Interop zwischen verschiedenen Programmiersprachen. Also, wenn ich jetzt
zum Beispiel von.NET Rust verwenden will, ist das ziemlich einfach. Macht nichts, ob
das im Kernel ist oder nicht. Also, wenn ich jetzt von.NET aus Rust verwenden will, ist
das relativ einfach. Rust kannst du so ziemlich allem easy ein C-Interface verpassen und dann
kannst du es aufrufen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es nicht schon wieder irgendwelche verrückten
Leute gibt, die die native Rust-Interop für.NET gebaut haben, keine Ahnung. Mit Go ist
das zwar theoretisch möglich, habe ich auch schon gemacht, haben wir auch schon im Stream
gemacht, ist aber alles andere als schön gelöst. Zumal C-Go auch so ein halb unsupporter
Ding ist, wo sich die Go-Entwickler nicht für interessieren. Und das zweite Problem
an Go ist, das ist meistens kein Problem interop-technisch, aber es hat halt ziemlich ein Overhead. Also,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Schleife mache über, sag mal ich lese ein Video ein,
Video-Files. Ich lese Videos ein mit FFmpeg und möchte dann die einzelnen Bilder irgendwie
bearbeiten. Ist egal, hat jetzt für das Beispiel nichts zu tun. Dann muss ich quasi für jedes
Bild, also quasi 60x in der Sekunde, also wenn ich es mit FPS mache, oder eben so schnell
wie es geht, so schnell wie es meine SSD hergibt, also dann mehrere hunderttausendmal pro Sekunde
wahrscheinlich, müsste ich dann einen Call machen von.NET nach Go. Und da fängt es
dann schon halt an mit Go problematisch zu werden, weil Interop mit Go immer einen hardcodeden
Overhead quasi hat. Die machen da irgendwelche speziellen Checks, mit welchem Thread du bist,
Widerspeicher, blablabla, die machen ganz viel Zeug. Und dementsprechend ist ein Call
von Programmiersprache X über irgendein C-Interface zu Go rein viel, viel, viel langsamer als
bei den meisten anderen Programmiersprachen. Noch schlimmer wird es, wenn du von Go selbst
was aufrufst aufs andere Sprachen. Und wie gesagt, auch diese ganze C-Go-Geschichte ist
nicht schön gemacht. Dementsprechend, ich finde es gut, dass viele Sachen in Rust programmiert
werden. Es mir lieber als in Go. War ja klar, dass jetzt wieder jemand kommt. Die Rust Taskforce
ist ja auch schon angerückt. Wenn du eine neue Programmiersprache oder Framework lernen
würdest, wie würdest du anfangen? YouTube Dokumentation? Äh, YouTube. Immer wenn ich
mir was Neues angucken will, das erste, was ich mache, ist, ich gucke, ob es mal irgendso
ein Übersichtsvideo auf YouTube gibt. Das finde ich immer ganz angenehm. Einer, der
ein bisschen was erklärt und was zeigt, da kriegt man meist schon ein ganz gutes Gefühl
dafür, wie es denn so ist, ungefähr. Also wenn ich mir was Neues angucke, das erste,
was ich mache, ist, ich gucke, ob es vielleicht nicht irgendwelche Übersichts-YouTube-Videos
gibt. Die offizielle Dokumentation gucke ich vielleicht mal ins Getting Started rein,
aber dann eigentlich nur, wenn ich irgendwas wissen muss. Beziehungsweise, wenn ich nicht
direkt mit Google und Stack Overflow finde. Und ansonsten tatsächlich Bücher. Bücher
habe ich lange keine mehr gekauft. Wahrscheinlich nicht Bücher, aber wahrscheinlich würde
ich mir irgendwelche Blog-Posts, Tutorials, Konferenztalks und Tutorials angucken. Eventuell
würde ich mir auch einen Kurs kaufen, je nachdem, was es ist, wenn es einen guten Kurs gibt.
Ja, Flutter kann ich leider nichts zu sagen. Habe ich nicht viel zu gemacht. Das einzige,
was wir mal gemacht haben im Stream ist eine Minimal-App. Keine Ahnung. Kennst du eigentlich
schon Dekker? Das ist eine Powerpoint-Alternative, die man mit Markdown nutzen kann, die von
Leuten aus meiner Uni entwickelt wird und irgendwie schon recht beliebt ist. Muss ich
jetzt nicht dran denken wegen MD für Skill? Was? Dekker? Github. Dekker. Ah nee, Moment,
nicht docker. Dekker. Dekker-Tool, hier. Oh ja, ist ja sehr beliebt. Nee, Moment. GitLab
2 Informatik-Uni Westburg. Ernsthaft nicht auf Github gehostet? Dann verschenkt ihr viel
Potenzial, wenn ihr das nicht auf Github postet. Was ist Stack? Huskell. MonkaS, Alter. Wo
ist denn der Source-Code hier überhaupt jetzt? Source? Windows? MonkaS. Oh, hör mal auf.
Das ist mir zu Sixhead. Gucken wir uns morgen alles an. Das stimmt, die Go-Website ist ziemlich
gut gewesen. Ja, das ist richtig. Stimmt, ich erinnere mich, ja. Darkion, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Oder ist eher Dark-Ion? Darkie-Ion vielleicht? Dankeschön, zwei Monate Massive
Subscription, ja. Boost-Train. Nee, nee, wir brauchen jetzt nicht mehr boosten, ich bin
in zehn Minuten auf. Also ich hab so ein paar Channels abonniert für bestimmte Themen, die
finde ich gut. Also ich guck wirklich gerne YouTube-Videos. Also für.NET ist der Typ
hier wirklich gut. Auf YouTube. Kann man es echt gut geben. Erfährt man auch öfters
mal neue Sachen, die man auch nicht kennt. Ist zum Beispiel so ein.NET-Channel, den
kann man wirklich empfehlen zu gucken. Ist auch immer übersichtlich. Viertelstunde Video.
Ja, Tim Corry ist mir ein bisschen zu ausführlich. Der erzählt dir, wie du Text-Logs eineinhalb
Stunden lang. Denk ich mir immer so Residenz-Sleeper. Ich mach meine Bewerbung garantiert nicht
in Reveal.js. Ja, John Skeet ist eh der Oberchecker, aber da macht er ja keine Tutorials und keinen
regelmäßigen YouTube-Content. Der hat ein paar interessante Konferenz-Talks. Der Bär,
also eins muss ich sagen, John Skeet hat einen super Konferenz-Talk zu Zeitzonen und Daytime
Libraries. Und generell zu Daytime Libraries. Daher weiß ich zum Beispiel auch, dass Schweden
das einzige Land der Welt ist, was mal ein 31. Februar oder so in der Richtung hatte.
Und warum? Weil sie vergessen haben, ihren Kalender umzustellen. Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo
sie es eigentlich wollten. Und dann mussten sie quasi den 31. Februar machen, dass sie
ihn wieder aufgeholt haben. Sie haben es vergessen, weil sie in irgendeinem Krieg verwickelt
waren und dann mussten sie es nach dem Krieg wieder aufholen mit einem 31. Februar. Das
habe ich bei einer John Skeet-Präsentation mal gelernt. Tainser! Na, 40 Monate, Alter,
Massive. Huge, nice. Massive, nice. Dankeschön für den Zap. Wir brauchen langsam echt mal
neue Kekse. Meine Gold-Kekse, den hat man ja schon nach einem Jahr. Aber die, die die
Kekse designt hat, die hat glaube ich andere Probleme gerade. Die kommt soweit, ich war
jetzt aus der Ukraine und ist irgendwie jetzt geflohen. Gut, vielleicht braucht sie ja auch
Geld und macht ein paar Emotes. Kann ja auch sein. Aber ich glaube, die hat andere Probleme
gerade. Machst du noch was mit dem Friseur? Der Friseur drückt sich immer. Wir wollten
schon letzten zwei Jahre Weihnachtsvideos aufnehmen. Der drückt sich immer. Der sagt
immer, lass mal machen und dann will er dann immer nicht. Ich mache heute nichts mehr,
ich gehe gleich pennen in fünf Minuten. Kommt bestimmt bald, kommt bestimmt bald. Kommt bestimmt
dann, wenn ein gutes Battlefield mal wieder rauskommt. Der muss BDO cryen? Nee, glaube
ich nicht. Spielt er wieder BDO? Wirklich? Glaub ich nicht, oder? Ich hab die schon ewig
nicht mal im Stream gesehen. Nee. Zuletzt hat er irgendwelche komischen Weep Games gespielt,
euch das mal an, ihr. Ist eigentlich echt schade, dass er nicht mal streamt. Nee, das
bist du nicht. Der Friseur ist Unterwäsche-Model in Dresden, jetzt hab ich gehört. No cuppa.
Muss wohl wirklich so sein, es gibt wohl irgendwie ein Plakat in Dresden, wo man den Fabian in
Unterwäsche sieht. Ja, warum nicht? Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, das nur gehört, oder scheint auch zu stimmen. Neues Update ist nice, ich
glaube BDO werde ich nicht mal reingucken. Letzte, was ich gemacht habe, ist mein Account
umgezogen zu einem anderen Anbieter. Naja, gut Leute, jetzt wird's aber mal langsam Zeit.
Machen wir anderen mal weiter, ich speicher auf jeden Fall mal. Mach VMS aus, ich geh
jetzt pennen, wir sehen uns morgen früh. Aufwachen Stream, diesmal gibt's auch einen,
letzte Woche Sonntag, ging nicht. Ja, kann sein, ja. Aber auch noch, weil der Fabian
gesagt hat, mach das lieber. Ich geh jetzt ins Bett, morgen früh, so, keine Ahnung, neun
Uhr oder so, oder kurz vor neun, oder kurz nach neun, wahrscheinlich eher kurz vor neun.
Machen wir Aufwachen Stream, gucken wir uns mal an, ob uns Level Cap wieder jebaitet,
oder was sonst so anliegt. Bis dann Leute, macht's gut, C U.